WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. FOR
TUESDAY. JUNE EIGHTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND I WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME EVERYONE TO THIS
HEARING COLLUDING HEARST GUPTA.
I WOULD LIKE TO MENTION THAT A
COUPLE OF TECHNICAL AND
PRACTICAL ISSUES FOR THE
HEARING BEFORE WE GET STARTED.
WE DURING WE STILL HAVE A CAN
STAY HOME ORDER CONTINUING AND
ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE CAPITAL
SO EVERYONE DOES NEED TO BE
PROPERLY MASS. AND I WILL NOTE
THAT THAT IS THE RULE ALSO OF
THE COMMITTEE. THAT BEING
PROPERLY MASK IS BEING PROPERLY
ATTIRED. YEAH BECAUSE OF SPACE
LIMITATIONS NOT EVERYONE CAN BE
IN THE HEARING ROOM TODAY. SO
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE IN THE
HEARING ROOM PLEASE REMAIN
APPROPRIATELY SPACED. AND
THROUGHOUT AS WELL AS
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL AND IF
YOU DO WANT TO TESTIFY ON ANY
BILLS THAT WE HAVE TODAY WE DO
YOU HAVE SOME ROOM HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM YOU'RE WELCOME TO
COME JOIN US HERE SPACE
AVAILABILITY OF COURSE PENDING
AND THEN WE HAVE THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. AT THE NORTH
SIDE OF THE CAPITOL AS WELL AS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY VIA
TELEPHONE. SO IF YOU'RE IN THE
ROOM WE DO ASK THAT IF YOU WANT
TO SPEAK ON A PARTICULAR BILL
RAISE YOUR HAND AND I'LL ASK
YOU TO COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE- WE DO WANT TO
ENSURE THAT NO ONE TOUCHES THE
MICROPHONE TO KEEP IT AS CLEAN
AS POSSIBLE. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE WATCHING THIS
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT BY
TELEPHONE. DURING THE HEARING-
YOU CAN CALL IN TO THE TOLL
FREE NUMBER WHICH IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AGAIN
THAT IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO- TO.
AGAIN ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
TWO- TO THOSE NUMBERS SHOULD BE
ON YOUR SCREEN THERE ALSO ON
THE WEBSITE FOR THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. RIGHT M. PLEASE DO
DALY AND WHEN YOU'RE ITEM COMES
UP SO THAT THE OPERATOR CAN
MAKE SURE WE CAN GET YOU IN THE
QUEUE. AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
SO WE ON THE- BARBARA GENDA
ITEM NUMBER TEN SB SEVEN SIXTY
TWO WHITE CAL SKI HAS BEEN
PULLED FROM THE HEARING TODAY'S
THAT IS NOT ON OUR AGENDA IT
WAS ON OUR CONSENT AGENDA. AND.
IT'S LIKE WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
SO WE'LL START OFF WITH
CONCORD. STONE HERE CHAU. CHIU
DAVIES GONZALEZ. HOLDEN KALRA.
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN RADIUS SMITH.
THE FED WELCOME ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SMITH BACK TO THE COMMITTEE IS
SITTING IN TODAY FOR MR
GALLAGHER RIGHT OUR FIRST BILL
IS ITEM NUMBER ONE SB FOUR
FIFTY FOUR SENATOR BATES. ONE
OF WELCOME. A GOOD MORNING- MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE AND THE SPONSOR
ON TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT I
DID ACCEPT PRIOR TO THE HEARING
THIS MORNING ON THE BILL SB
FIVE FIFTY FOUR- FOR FIFTY FOUR
WILL RAISE THE STATUTORY
THRESHOLD FOR FILING GOVERNMENT
CHILD SUPPORT PROPERTY AND
PERSONAL LIENS FROM ONE MONTH
SUPPORT TO A THOUSAND DOLLARS
OR THREE MONTHS IN ARREARS
CURRENTLY COUNTY CHILD SUPPORT
AGENCIES ARE REQUIRED BY
STATUTE TO RECORD LEANS AGAINST
REAL OR PERSONAL PROPERTY ANY
TIME. A CHILD SUPPORT DEBTOR
OWES MORE THAN ONE MONTH WORTH
OF CHILD SUPPORT HOWEVER IN
MOST CASES THE RECORDATION AND
EVENTUAL RELEASE OF LEANS
PRODUCES NO COLLECTION BECAUSE
THE OBLIGATION HAS ALREADY BEEN
PAID THIS IN FOR IN FOR
ENFORCEMENT TOOL PROVIDES TO BE
PROVED TO BE EFFECTIVE FOR VERY
SMALL GROUP OF CASES THE
MAJORITY OF PROPERTY LIENS
COLLECTIONS DERIVE FROM CASES
WITH ARREARS BALANCES OF TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR GREATER IN
A MAJORITY OF CASES PARENTS
PAYING SUPPORT STAY IN
SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE WITH
THEIR SUPPORT ORDERS. BUT AS WE
ALL KNOW THINGS HAPPEN IN LIFE
AND SOMETIMES THE PAYMENT IS
MADE A DAY LATE THE FILING OF A
LEAN WHEN A PARENT IS ONLY ONE
MONTH IN ARREARS IS NOT ONLY A
BURDEN ON BOTH CHILD SUPPORT
AGENCIES BUT ON PARENTS WHO
TYPICALLY PAY THEIR CHILD
SUPPORT OBLIGATION ON TIME BY
RAISING THE THRESHOLD FOR
RECORDING LEANS FROM THE
CURRENT ONE MONTH TO ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR THREE
MONTHS IN ARREARS WOULD
ELIMINATE OVER 70% OF THE LIENS
BEING FILED. THE COST SAVINGS
TO COUNTY AGENCIES IN
IMPOSITION ON OTHERWISE PAYING
SUPPORT A BELIEVE GORE'S WOULD
BE SUBSTANTIAL WELL THE IMPACT
TO COLLECTIONS IS EXPECTED TO
BE MINIMAL I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK RENATO EASKEY ADA THE
CHIEF COUNSEL FOR THE ORANGE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES IN MARIE OURS
OLA THE INTERIM DIRECTOR- OF
ORANGE. COUNTY TO SERVICES FOR
BEING WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SENATOR I
DO HAVE THOSE TWO WITNESSES
LISTED MARIA ARE SODA AND
RONALDO'S GAITA. BOTH WITH US
ON THE TELEPHONE ARE EITHER OF
YOU HERE. YES WE ARE RIGHT HERE
AND RIGHT NOW TO GET THAT WILL
TESTIFY OKAY. GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. AMBER NOT TO SKIP THE
CHIEF ATTORNEY ORANGE COUNTY
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES AGENCY.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY THIS MORNING ON BEHALF
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. HOW DO CHILD
SUPPORT AGENCIES ARE REQUIRED
BY CURRENT STATUTE RECORD LEANS
AGAINST REAL PROPERTY ANYTIME A
CHILD SUPPORT DEBTOR OWES MORE
THAN ONE MONTH'S WORTH OF CHILD
SUPPORT. HOWEVER THE RECORD
DACIAN AND EVENTUAL RELEASE OF
LANES MAY NOT PRODUCE
COLLECTION BECAUSE THE
OBLIGATION HAS ALREADY BEEN
PAID. PROPERTY LIENS PROVED TO
BE EFFECTIVE FOR A VERY SMALL
GROUP OF CASES. THE MAJORITY OF
COLLECTIONS ARE OCCUR THANK
CASES WITH THE REAR BALANCES OF
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS OR GREATER.
FOLLOWING THE LEAN WHEN A
PARENT IS ONLY ONE MONTH IN
ARREARS IT'S A BIRD AND ON BOTH
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES AND
PARENTS WHO TYPICALLY PAY THEIR
SUPPORT OBLIGATION ON TIME AND
TO STAY IN SUBSTANTIAL
COMPLIANCE WITH THEIR SUPPORT
ORDERS. EACH YEAR ORANGE COUNTY
CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES RECORDS
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN THOUSAND
NEW LANES. AND RECEIVES OVER
SEVEN THOUSAND REQUEST TO
RELEASE LANES. OF THOSE
RELEASES OVER 90% OR FOR A
RELEASE OF LEAN FOR RICHARD
INSTALLMENT MEANING THERE WAS
NO MONEY OWED ON THE OBLIGATION.
STOCK COSTS ORANGE COUNTY CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES OVER A HUNDRED
AND FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR IN UNNECESSARY EXPENSE FOR
STAFF TIME. STATEWIDE THAT
WASTED EFFORT IS ESTIMATED TO
BE ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
ADULT. S. B. FOUR FIFTY FOUR
WITH THE MAN THE THRESHOLD FOR
FILING LIENS TWO ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THREE MONTHS IN
ARREARS WHICHEVER COMES FIRST.
THIS WOULD REDUCE THE BURDEN ON
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES
STATEWIDE ON ENFORCEMENT
MEASURE WHICH HAS NOT PROVEN
SUCCESSFUL. WITH THE MINIMAL
IMPACT ON CHILD SUPPORT
COLLECTIONS. WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE CHILD SUPPORT
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND I
STAYED IN THEIR LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE. THEY SUPPORT THE
INTENT OF THE MEASURE IN OUR
SYSTEM AS WITH TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS. WE ARE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
ASSOCIATION AND ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THEIR AND PUT.
ORANGE COUNTY IS PROUD TO
SPONSOR SB FOUR FIFTY FOUR IT
IS VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
CENTERPIECES INTRODUCTION OF
THE MEASURE. AS WELL AS FOR
STAFF'S ENGAGEMENT. AND THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY STAFF WORK
AND ASSISTANCE. SB FOUR FIFTY
FOUR IT'S A COMMONSENSE
APPROACH TO MANDATE A POLICY
THAT IS NOT EFFECTIVE.
THEREFORE THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS PURCHASE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. RIGHT AND I
TAKE IT MARIE OUR SOUL IS NOT
TESTIFYING. AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU. YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL THEN
GO TO OTHERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
FIFTY FOUR THIRTY ONE HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM SING NONE AT
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE. IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
ADVOCATE SUPPORT FOR S. B. FOUR
FIFTY FOUR. WE WILL BE TAKING
NAME. AFFILIATION AND THAT YOU
SUPPORT SB FIFTY FOUR OPERATOR
WHICH OPEN ALLIANCE PLEASE. YES
THANK YOU IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR FIFTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW.
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
OF S. B. FOUR FIFTY FOUR.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU WE WILL MOVED
OPPOSITION I DO NOT HAVE ANY
ONE LISTED IN OFFICIAL
OPPOSITION SO IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE. REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OF AS BEFORE FIFTY
FOUR. IN A POSITION OF SB FOUR
FIFTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO HERE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FOUR FIFTY FOUR. AND ONE MOMENT
WE DO HAVE ONE IN Q. AND THERE
IS A REMINDER IT IS- IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. FOUR FIFTY
FOUR. IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR
FIFTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND ONE MOMENT WHILE
WE GET THEIR NUMBER TO THEM
HERE. AND THEN WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN. AND
HONORABLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
THE- OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU. MY NAME IS ALEXIS SLOWLY
LEGISLATIVE INTERN WITH THE
CHILD SUPPORT DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION. CALLING IN TO
EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE TO THE
AUTHOR AND TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ACCEPTING THESE RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL. WE
APPRECIATE THE ATTENTION TO
CHILD UPPORT PROPERTY RULES
AND FEEL AT THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS WILL BENEFIT BOTH
PAYING AND RECEIVING PARENTS
AND LOCAL TRANSPORT SERVICE
AGENCIES. ON THE CUSTOMER
KIESLER. ADDITIONALLY WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR WORK
WITH THIS BILL AUTHORED. AND
SPONSORS TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
NO AMBIGUITY BETWEEN THE
MODIFIED STATUTES. AND EXISTING
REGULATIONS. THANK YOU. SO MUCH
FOR ALL YOUR WORK WITH THAT.
AND TO THINK. THANK YOU. THANK
IN WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME RIGHT. SECOND THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE A MOTION A SECOND THANK
YOU OPERATOR YOU MAY CLOSE
ALLIANCE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISS DAVIS AND SENATOR
BATES THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- I
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND IF YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR A CO AUTHOR WOULD
BE HAPPY TO BE PART OF IT.
THANK YOU AGAIN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CONSULT. I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY AND
I'VE NEVER SUPPORTED AT
ANYTHING THAT RELIEVES ANY TYPE
OF CHILD SUPPORT OF PEOPLE
REALIZED BUT I DO TAKE NOTE
WITH A FEW THINGS THAT WERE
SAID- IN THE DISCUSSION TO
SUGGEST THAT EVEN A DAY LATE
CHILD SUPPORT A DAY LATE HAS
PROFOUND IMPACT ON- THAT THE
RECIEVING- SPOUSE'S LIFE IT CAN
MEAN THAT THERE THEN LATE FOR
RENT IT CAN MEAN THAT YOU KNOW
THEIR CAR GETS REPOSSESS SO I
JUST WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR THAT
WE TALK ABOUT THIS IN A WAY.
THAT RESPECTS- THE NEED FOR
CHILD SUPPORT TO BE TIMELY
EVERY SINGLE MONTH IT IS I
UNDERSTAND ONEROUS TO DO A LEAN
IF SOMETHING IS A DAY LATE BUT
I DON'T IN ANY WAY WANT TO
EXCUSE- THAT TYPE OF ACTION-
OFTEN OFTEN DONE JUST TO BE OF.
CRUEL IN FACT TO THE RECEIVING
PARENTS SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT'S CLEAR BECAUSE THERE
WERE A COUPLE- POINTS THAT WERE
ACTED LIKE IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL
AND SOMEBODY NORMALLY PAYS
CHILD SUPPORT BUT IT IS
IMPORTANT EVERY SINGLE MONTH
CHILD SUPPORT ON TIME. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT IT'S
JUST LIKE US GETTING OUR
PAYCHECK LATE. AND THEREFORE IF
WE WAITED FOR THAT IN OUR PARKS
BIG BILL IS DUE THAT DAY WE'RE
IN TROUBLE FOR A LOT OF I TAKE
YOUR- COMMENTS VERY SERIOUSLY I
THINK THAT THE FIVE HAVING BEEN
A COUNTY SUPERVISOR AND I KNOW
AFFECTS OUR COUNTY SAN DIEGO IN
ORANGE COUNTY. SIGNIFICANTLY SO
IT DOES HELP. AND I THINK IT
TAKES THE BLEMISH AWAY FROM
THOSE WHO MIGHT BE. YOU KNOW
TWENTY FOUR HOURS LATER AND
THEN HAVE A LIEN ON THE CAR
WHATEVER. POSSESSIONS THEY
STILL HAVE THAT. GET TOP THIS
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND
PERHAPS ARE- COUNTY AUG.
SUPPORT AGENCY PERSONNEL CAN DO
A LITTLE BETTER EDUCATION HERE
WE'RE GIVING YOU A LITTLE BREAK
LET'S MAKE SURE WE'RE ALL ON
TIME BECAUSE- YOU KNOW WE-
MIGHT HAVE TO GO BACK THE OTHER
WAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION- AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMON SEE NONE
CENTER WILL TAKE THAT IS YOUR
CLOTHES. SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CALDERON PLEASE STONE HI STONE
I CHAO CHARGE CHIU DAVIES DAVEY
SEIGENTHALER'S GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN GREATEST REYES AYE
SMITH SMITH BY. THE BILLS OUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB TWENTY FOUR
CENTER CABALLERO TENNESSEE
COMES UP I'LL TAKE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT AGENDA. THANK YOU
HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA. CALDERON PLEASE
STONE BY STONE I CHOP CHOI CHU
DAVIS. DAVID BACK AND SALAS
CONSULTA HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES BOB
GRIESE AYE SMITH SMITH I THINK
YOU NOTICE SB THREE OH EIGHT
MEN. ACR EIGHTY THREE MCCARTY
HAD AJ ARE FIFTEEN MCCARTY
THANK YOU SENATOR. WELCOME GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT SB TWENTY FOUR WHICH
MAKES REVISIONS TO THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER FORM
TO PROTECT A CHILD SCHOOL
MEDICAL AND DENTAL INFORMATION
FROM AN ABUSIVE PARENT. THIS
BILL REQUIRES THIRD PARTY
INSTITUTIONS SUCH AS SCHOOLS
DENTAL OFFICES OR MEDICAL
OFFICES TO DEVELOP PROTOCOLS
WHEN THEY RECEIVE A COPY OF
SUCH A COURT RESTRAINING ORDER.
I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU A
TRAGIC DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASE
THAT WAS THE CATALYST FOR SB
TWENTY FOUR IT BEGINS WITH THE
YOUNG MOTHER CALLIE WHO LIVED
IN MADERA WITH THEIR THREE
YOUNG BOYS ALL UNDER THE AGE OF
SIX. KELLY LEFT HER HUSBAND IN
MAY OF TWENTY TWENTY AFTER
YEARS OF BRUTAL PHYSICAL
EMOTIONAL AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
ABUSE BECAUSE OF THE EMOTIONAL
ABUSE SHE WAS ISOLATED FROM HER
FAMILY AND FRIENDS AND WAS
AFRAID FOR THE SAFETY OF HER
VOICE AND FRANKLY BELIEVE THAT-
THERE WAS NO ONE THERE TO HELP
HER. WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SUPPORT
SHELTER SHE OBTAINED A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER AND
WENT INTO HIDING WITH THEIR
CHILDREN AND FINALLY CONTACTED
HER FAMILY FOR HELP. AFTER
SUCCESSFULLY HIDING FOR HER
HUSBAND FROM HER HUSBAND FOR
THREE MONTHS AND GETTING HELP
FOR HER AND HER BOYS CAL IMADE
AN APPOINTMENT AT A LOCAL
HEALTH CLINIC. THE CLINIC CALL
TO CONFIRM THE APPOINTMENT AND
CALLED KELLY'S HUSBAND. ON HIS
CELL PHONE SO THAT HE
INADVERTENTLY LEARNED AT THE
TIME AND THE LOCATION OF THE
APPOINTMENT ON JULY FOURTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY CALORIES A
STRANGE STRANGE AND VIOLENT
HUSBAND DROVE TO THE CLINIC
WAITED IN THE PARKING LOT WHEN
SHE ARRIVES SHOT AND KILLED HER
IN BROAD DAYLIGHT AND SHE
SHIELDED THEIR THREE YOUNG
CHILDREN FROM THE BULLETS. I
BRING KELLY STORY TO YOUR
ATTENTION BECAUSE IN THE REALM
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THIS LEVEL
OF CONTROL PLANNING AND
PERPETUAL VIOLENCE IS
UNFORTUNATELY NO NOT IN AND
CALL. A IT IS PROJECTED THAT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HAS RAVAGED
OUR COMMUNITIES AT EVEN HIGHER
RATES. SINCE THE ONSET OF THE
PANDEMIC. FOR THOSE IN ABUSIVE
RELATIONSHIPS THE RISKS THEY
FACE FEET FACE IN LEAVING THEIR
PARTNERS MAY BE JUST AS
DANGEROUS AS THE RISK OF
STAYING PUT. UP 275% OF ABUSED
WOMEN. WHO ARE MURDERED ARE
KILLED AFTER THEY LEAVE THEIR
PARTNER'S. VIOLENT PERPETRATORS
TO MURDER THEIR EX PARTNERS GO
TO GREAT LENGTHS TO TRACT TRACT
THEIR VICTIMS AND ONE STRATEGY.
UTILIZED BY ABUSIVE PARTNERS IS
TO TRACK THE LOCATION OF THE
SHARED SHARED CHILDREN. THIS IS
WHY OBTAINING A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER IS
VITAL TO SURVIVORS. THE
PROTECTIVE ORDERS REQUIRE THE
PERPETRATOR TO REFRAIN FROM
HAVING ANY CONTACT WITH THE
VICTIM AND THEIR CHILDREN.
CURRENTLY A JUDGE CAN GRANT A
MULTITUDE OF DIFFERENT
PROTECTIONS FOR THE ABUSE
PARTY. INCLUDING ORDERS THAT
PROTECT THE MEDICAL AND SCHOOL
INFORMATION OF THE SHARE
CHILDREN. HOWEVER WHILE A JUDGE
ALREADY HAS THIS DISCRETION
THERE'S NO PLACE ON THE ACTUAL
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER FORM. THEREFORE WHEN A
PROTECTIVE ORDER IS PRINTED AND
GIVEN TO THE PARTIES INVOLVED.
IT DOES NOT EXPLICITLY STATE
SAY THAT SCHOOL MEDICAL OR
DENTAL INFORMATION ABOUT THE
SHARED CHILDREN BE PROTECTED
FROM THE PERPETRATOR. THIS
MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR A SCHOOL
OR MEDICAL OFFICE TO ENFORCE IF
THERE'S NO CLEAR LANGUAGE
STATING OTHERWISE. THEN THESE
THIRD PARTY INSTITUTIONS WILL
NOT DENY APPARENT THEIR LEGAL
RIGHT TO INFORMATION ABOUT
THEIR CHILD WHICH IS. IF THIS
YOU KNOW THE WHOLE IDEA OF A
PARENT HAVING INFORMATION ABOUT
THEIR CHILDREN IS REALLY A
SACRED RIGHT IN. IN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO- IF
YOU'RE GOING TO BE SO IF YOU'RE
GOING TO DECIDE AS A JUDGE THAT
YOU WANT. TO PROTECT THE
CHILDREN AND THEIR WHEREABOUTS-
INCLUDING DENTAL AND MEDICAL
VISITS AND OF AN APPOINTMENT.
THEN THAT THERE SHOULD BE A
PLACE ON THE FORM THAT MAKES IT
VERY EASY TO CHECK OFF AND- AND
BE ABLE TO PROTECT THE- THE
ESCAPING FAMILY MEMBERS. WE
HAVE TO OFFER MORE PROTECTION
FOR PEOPLE LIKE KELLY SB TWENTY
FOUR IS A SIMPLE STEP TO OFFER
BETTER PROTECTION. FOR
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND THEIR CHILDREN. WITH ME
TODAY IS SERRA RODRIGUEZ
KELLY'S COUSIN. WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SAY A FEW WORDS AND DAN BT
FROM THE ALEXANDRA ADVOCACY
GROUP TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I DO HAVE THE TWO
WITNESSES SIR ROD REGUS WITH US
ON THE TELEPHONE AND DAN
BEATTIE. ALSO WITH US ON THE
TELEPHONE SERRA RODRIGUEZ. YES
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
ME TODAY I APOLOGIZE FOR MY
VOICE. I HOPE YOU CAN HEAR ME
CLEARLY BUT FIRST I WOULD AGAIN
LIKE TO THANK THE SENATORS AND
THEIR STAFF AND EVERYONE ELSE
THAT HELPED. AND SUPPORTED
CALLIPHORIDAE FOUR. HIGHER THAN
A MEETING PERSON I KNOW WE
ALWAYS SAY THAT ABOUT PEOPLE.
QALQILYA AS- KELLY LET ROOM HER
LAST WAS FELT BY IT MATTERS NOT
CONTAINS. AFTER MANY OF ABUSE
PHYSICAL MENTAL EMOTIONAL ABUSE
CALIFORNIA COURAGE TO ASK FOR
HELP. HONESTLY I THINK THAT
COURAGE CAME FROM BEING A MOM-
PETER HAD BROKERS SO FAR. BUT I
THINK. BEING A MOM DAY PROJECT
TO BETTER HELP SOMETHING TO
SLEEP FOR. WHEN WE HELP
TRANSLATE ON MAY FIFTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY JUST OVER A YEAR
AGO. SHE WAS ALMOST
UNRECOGNISABLE SHE WOULDN'T
MAKE EYE CONTACT SHE WOULDN'T
HARDLY SPEAK LESS YOU ASKED
SOMETHING. EVEN THEN SHE HAD NO
OPINION AND MADE NO COMPLAINT
AND SHE APOLOGIZED FOR
EVERYTHING AND ANYTHING. BUT
WHEN SHE INTERACTED WITH THE
BOYS YOU COULD BE HER. STILL IN
THEIR PLEASE WITH THEM FOR
MONTHS AT A TIME. AND JUST
LISTENING TO THE HORRIFIC
STORIES OF THINGS HE HAD DONE.
THINGS YOU'LL ONLY SEE ON TV.
SHE TOLD SHE WAS CALLED EVERY
DAY HER ONLY PURPOSE BUT THIS
THERE CAN. BE COUNTY NEW THAT
WASN'T SURE SHE KNEW HER
PRACTICE SUCH PROJECTED
SOMETHING. KELLY SAID HER
BIGGEST FEAR. AND WHAT MADE HER
FINAL ME BUT THAT ISSUE
DEFINITELY. WOULD KILL THEM ALL
SHE WANTED TO END THE CYCLE OF
ABUSE SHE LOVED HER CHILDREN
AND DID NOT WANT THERE. EVER BE
A CHANCE THAT THEY CAN GROW UP
ANYTHING LIKE HIM SHE WANTED
HER CHILDREN TO KNOW WHAT A
LOVING FAMILY WAY. OF LIFE AND
WOULDN'T LIKE TO BE A KID. THE
LONGER SHE WAS FREE THE MORE
SHE WAS RECOGNIZED AGAIN NOT BY
JUST US BUT SHE COULD RECOGNIZE
YOURSELF AGAIN. YOU CAN SEE HER
FIGHTING. COULD BE CREATION.
SHEILA YOU THAT IF YOU'RE FOR
HER AND HER KIDS HER FAMILY
WITH PEOPLE SHEILA AND PEOPLE
WHO LOVE THEM. SHE WAS ABLE TO
FINALLY TELL HER TREE AND BEGIN
HEALING. SHE WAS SO MAKING OF
GLOBALIZATION SHE WAS STAYING
IN A WOMEN'S SHELTER AND SPOKE
HERE. YEAH SHE WAS EXTREMELY
CAREFULLY GOING TO COURT HAS TO
BE DONE BECAUSE INTO DATE
PREPARE. JUST THE STATE. ON
JULY FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY.
KELLY HAD AN APPOINTMENT
CAMARENA HEALTH PLAN EMPLOYEE
HAD TOLD HER ESTRANGED HUSBAND
OF HER APPOINTMENT. HE WAITED
FOR HER AS SHE EXITED THE
DOCTOR'S OFFICE AND STANDING AT
THE SHELTER DOWN HE GUNNED IT
DOWN. YOU KNOW WHAT. DOT COULD
GET HER ONCE. THEY ARE. YOU TOO
BYE TO PROTECT ABOUT BURKE CHAU.
MONSTER CHECKERSPOT JUST GOT
BACK SHE'S HERE. SHE WE GET TO
PROTECT CHILDREN ON JULY THIRTY
SHE GAVE LIFE. RIGHT.
THANK YOU
I KNOW THAT'S VERY VERY
DIFFICULT. TO GIVE THAT KIND OF
TESTIMONY DN BEATTIE. DANBURY
ARE YOU WITH US. OPERATOR IS
THERE DIEM BEATTY ALLY. LET ME
CHECK FOR HIM ONE MOMENT. HELLO
HELLO. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS DIANE BEATTY I AM THE
CO FOUNDER ALONG WITH MY HAD
BEEN RANKED AND BIALIK FOUNDER
FOUNDATION AN ADVOCACY GROUP
THESE ORGANIZATIONS ARE NAMED
IN HONOR OF MY SWEET DAUGHTER
ALESSANDRA WHO WAS BRUTALLY
MURDERED BY HER EX BOYFRIEND IN
OCTOBER. TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
TWO WEEKS AFTER SHE BROKE UP
WITH HIM. WE OFFER OUR
WHOLEHEARTED SUPPORT FOR
PASSAGE OF SB TWENTY FOUR HOURS
HUNDRED MURDERS BANTER ABOUT
TWO AND A HALF YEARS IN JAIL
AND A BAT FOR ATTEMPTING TO
MURDER A PREVIOUS GIRLFRIEND.
OF COURSE SALAS FOUNDER AND WE
KNEW NOTHING OF HIS HISTORY OR
CONVICTION UNTIL THE AFTERMATH
OF HER MURDER. ALESSANDRA AND
THE OTHER WOMEN WERE NOT
OFFERED ANY WAY TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES FROM PREDATORS LIKE
KIM. ALEXANDER ADVOCACY GROUP
WAS FORMED TO PARTNER WITH
OFFICIALS AND LEGISLATORS TO
CRAFT THIS STATUTE TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC TO READ VIEW INFORMATION
ABOUT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CONVICTIONS VIA AND ABUSE THEIR
SEARCH ENGINE. IT WOULD ALLOW
AN NGO ACCESS TO PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE DATA AND PUBLISH IT
TO PROTECT POTENTIAL DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VICTIMS. IT IS COMMON
SENSE LEGISLATION TO PROTECT
VICTIMS AND NOT CONVICTED
CRIMINAL. DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
WITHIN OUR HEADLINES ON A DAILY
BASIS WE CANNOT BECOME NUMB TO
IT AND THE EFFECT IT. HAS ON
EVERY ASPECT OF SOCIETY.
SENATOR YEAH HAS UP FOR VICTIMS
DENTIST FULL AND WAY AND WE
STAND WITH HER. KELLY HAD
ESCAPED HER ABUSER ONLY TO BE
EXPOSED VIA A TRAGIC MISTAKE
THAT COST HER HER LIFE AND
CHANGED YOUR CHILDREN'S LIVES
FOREVER. I AM A SURVIVOR OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE MY FIRST
MARRIAGE ENDED IN NINETEEN
NINETY WITH ME FLEEING WITH MY
SON AARON AND DAUGHTER
ALEXANDER TO BATTERED WOMEN'S
SHELTER IT SAVED MY LIFE.
PLEASE DO EVERYTHING TO PROTECT.
INFORMATION ABOUT VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WHO HAVE FLED
AND RECEIVE PROTECTIVE ORDERS.
AGAIN THANK YOU ALL AND MAY GOD
GUIDE AND BLESS YOU. THANK YOU
THIRTY ONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY FOUR.
SEEING NONE AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO. INDICATE SUPPORT FOR S. B.
TWENTY FOUR WE ARE TAKING NAMES
AFFILIATIONS AND SUPPORT. DO
YOU IF YOU AREN'T A PART OF SB
TWENTY BEFORE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
NOW AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY
FOUR. AND WE WILL GO TO A LINE
OF THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING PAUL YODER
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE UP
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN DOWN IN
MEMBERS THIS IS ALICE. VIOLENCE
IN SUPPORT AND SB TWENTY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO A
PHOTO LINEUP TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS CHAD PACKED
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND WE
SUPPORTED BELL. THANK YOU IN
MEXICO LINE OF TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS BETHANY BIRD I AM THE
FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF PIPESTONE OPEN DOOR FOR
TRAUMA AND ABUSE FROM DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL ABUSE. AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
YOU AN EXTRA GOAL LINE OF
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE MORNING CARE MEMBERS OF THE
JESSICA TEN ON BEHALF OF THE
GREAT AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
OPERATOR WE WILL NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE NONE. LISTED
HERE TODAY SO IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWENTY FOUR. SIGNETICS REMOTE
TESTIMONY SAY. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO SB
TWENTY FOUR. IF YOU IF YOU'RE
IN OPPOSITION- SB TWENTY FOUR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION OF SB TWENTY FOUR.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE UP
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MARIA OVER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WE DO NOT HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE BELL-
WE DO HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
OUR ABILITY TO OPERATIONALIZE
HOWEVER. AND I'D REALLY LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHORS OFFICE FOR
WORKING WITH US AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITE
MAKE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
ARE PRETTY MAY CLOSE ALLIANCE
OF BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND. QUESTIONS
COMMENTS RIGHT BUT MISTAKES
THINKING THIS CAVALEIRO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD IT WHAT'S AMAZING
TO ME IS THAT WE HAVEN'T HAD
THIS BILLS YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN
TOO LONG FOR THIS AND AS YOU
SAID SUCH A LARGE PERCENT OF
THESE WOMEN AND MEN- YOU KNOW
LOSE THEIR LIVES AFTERWARDS SO
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BRING
THIS UP- IT'S GONNA MAKE A
DIFFERENCE SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND I WOULD BE HONORED TO
BE A CO AUTHOR OF THIS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU OTHER QUESTIONS COMMON.
SIGNALED SENATOR KABIR YOU MAY
CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTED. THE PRESENTED
BILL TODAY. THANK YOU. WE DO
HAVE A MOTIONS. MOST TO PAY. TO
APPROACH. KALRA STONED BY STONE
I CHAU. CHAO AYE CHIU. DAVIS
DAVIES ARKANSAS. CONSULT I HOLD
KALRA. CALL RIGHT. KILEY AYE
MAIN SHOW REYES. REYES ICE.
SMITH I. THANK THANK YOU
SENATOR DORADO I DON'T KNOW
THREE TWO NINETY SO. MORNING
OKAY THE MORE. A GOOD MORE THE
PROCEDURE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M PRESENTE SP TWO
NIGHT SEVEN WE WOULD CREE US
PENALTY UP TO ONE THOUSAND. FOR
AN OP OR EXT. WHO AFTER TO
FOLLOW DAY ALERT REQUIRED
DAMAGES SUB IN. AND CAUSES THE
OF HAZARDOUS GAS LIQUID
CURRENTLY YOU'RE GO TO S. OR
THE SUB AND INSTALLATION YOU
ARE WE BY LAW TO CALL EIGHT
WILL NOTED SO. TO ENSURE THAT
YOU DON'T DAMAGE SOME CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BURIED BENEATH
THE SURFACE THIS IS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT PROVIDES-OUR ENERGY OUR WATER
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND SO ON.
IT IS NO SMALL THING WHEN AN
EXCAVATOR FAILS TO MAKE THIS
CALL DAMAGING SOMETHING'S BELOW
THE SURFACE IS NOT ONLY COSTLY
AND POTENTIALLY DISRUPTIVE BUT
IT CAN ALSO BE EXTREMELY
DANGEROUS TO THE WORKERS AND
THE PUBLIC. THIS BILL IS IN
HONOR OF ONE SUCH WORKER WHO
TRAGICALLY LOST HIS LIFE WHEN A
SOLAR COMPANY FAILED TO CALL
EIGHT ONE ONE AND DAMAGED A GAS
LINE SOCALGAS EMPLOYEE WOULD
KILL PATRICK AND HIS CREW WERE
CALLED OUT TO FIX THE PROBLEM
AND DURING THEIR WORK THE
LEAKING GAS WAS IGNITED. AND MR
KILPATRICK WAS CLEAR KILLED IN
THE EXPLOSION THIS TRAGEDY
COULD HAVE BEEN AVOIDED HAD THE
SOLAR COMPANY FOLLOWED THE LAW
MORE SIGNIFICANT PENALTIES WILL
PUNISH THE BAD ACTORS AND
HOPEFULLY PROVIDE SOME
INCENTIVE FOR OTHERS TO SIMPLY
CALL EIGHT ONE ONE. I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES TODAY- ERR KAUFMAN
WHO IS PRESIDENT OF THE UTILITY
WORKERS UNION LOCAL ONE THIRTY
TWO AND SHANE GOES MONTH THEIR.
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I DID NOT
HAVE THOSE NAMES SO WE DO NOW
ERIC HOFFMAN ARE YOU WITH US ON
THE LINE. M. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHAIRMAN STONE MISTING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ERIC HOFFMAN AND I AM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UTILITY
WORKERS IN AMERICA LOCAL ONE
THIRTY TWO. SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REPRESENT NEARLY FOUR THOUSAND
WORKERS AT SO CAL GAS AND I
ALSO SERVED AS ONE OF THE VICE
PRESIDENTS THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FEDERATION OF LABOR. I'M
HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY URGING
YOUR UNWAVERING SUPPORT AND
COMMITMENT TO SB TWO NINETY
SEVEN THERE ALTHOUGH THE WAY TO
PATRICK GET GAP SAFETY ACT. ON
JULY. TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. WE
LOST OUR FALLEN BROTHER WAIT
TILL PATRICK DUE TO IN. ON ON.
WORKPLACE INCIDENT. IN WHICH
LICENSE CONTRACT WHO KNEW THE
OF EIGHT ONE DECLARE LAWS. FOR
TO BREAK THE LAW AND THEN OF A
DONE BASS. WHICH ALL LED TO OUR
UNION BROTHER WAY UP AFTER
SACRA. HIS LIFE IN AN EFFORT TO
KEEP HELPING KEEPING CAN SAFE.
I WANT TO BE. THIS IS NOT IN A
TEN AS ON. RED TAPE OR BEAR. TO
EXISTING. BUT RATHER BUT RATHER
THIS BILL PROVIDE AN ESSENTIAL
ADDITIONAL LAYER OF WORKPLACE
SAFETY BY PREVENTING BAD PAID
CONTRACTORS FROM KNOWINGLY
COMMITTING GROSS NEGLIGENCE
BECAUSE WITHOUT THIS BILL. THE
STAKES JUST AREN'T HIGH ENOUGH
FOR THEM WHILE ARE HIGH ENOUGH
FOR US AND I BESEECH ALL OF YOU
TO PLEASE GIVE THIS BILL THE
CONSIDERATION THAT WAIT TILL
PATRICK. AND HIS FAMILY
DESERVES THIS BILL IS FORUMS
WORKER STATE. IT FOR FEW KERN
FOR THE HURT. CANADA FORWARD.
IN THAT THE VENT MATHIS
EMISSION DUE TO DO IN SOME
PROGRAMS LINE. AND TILL PASSED.
HAS FOR. AND ALL OF HIS
BROTHERS AND HERE AT THE U. WAY
ARE THIS BILL FOR. I THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR TIME. FOR THIS
LEGISLATION I WANT TO THANK OUR
INCREDIBLE CENTER MARLON. THE
FOR AND FOR AND INSPIRING. AND
THAT'S THAT'S BANK TO STAFF AS
WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SINGLES ONE. GOOD MORE MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LIKE- SHINGLES
FROM BEHALF TO THE UTILITY USE
OF AMERICA- CPAS THERE LOCAL
REPRESENTING GAS WORK ACROSS
SOUTHERN- AND REST OF IT EIGHT-
HOW DO YOU VERY BRIEF THIS WAY
IS A WORK SAFETY BILL AND- I
JUST WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WE WILL WITH-
TO COME TO- CAN- BILL THAT I DO.
EVERYONE WERE THERE ARE AND WE
HAVE A LOW MARGIN SUPPORT FROM
THEM CAN- AND I GUESS WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE THEM URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW GO
TO OTHER SUPPORT THERE IS NO
ONE IN THE HEARING ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE. AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. C. NONE I
WOULD YOU OVER THE LINES ANYONE
WHO LIKE TO SUPPORT FOR S. B.
TWO. SEVEN BEGIN WE'RE JUST
TAKING NAME OF. AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
SB TWO NINETY SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
AND THEN ZERO IF YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO NINETY
SEVEN. AND WE WILL GO TO A LINE
OF THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MURS
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO EXPORT. THANK YOU. AND
AGAIN WE ARE ON S. B. TWO
NINETY SEVEN AND SUPPORT. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF FORTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST HOT
BALLOON SIGN FOR THE
UNDERGROUND SERVICE ALERT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. COMMONLY
CALLED THE DICK ALERT IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE NEXT TO GO LINE
OF TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING- MISTER
CHAIR NUMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ISRAEL SALAS WITH SOCAL GAS AND
SAN DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU WE'LL
MOVED OPPOSITION I DO NOT HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION. LISTED THERE'S
NO ONE IN THE HEARING ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR YOU WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO SB
TWO NINETY SEVEN. IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO NINETY
SEVEN YOU MY PRESS ONE AND
THEN. ZERO AND THEN AND THERE
APPEARED OPPOSITION OF SB. TWO
NINETY SEVEN. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO OPPOSITION IN Q. THANK
YOU OPERATOR YOU MAY CLOSE LOT
OF BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. SEEING NOTHING ELSE
SENDIRI MICHELOB'S THANK YOU
ALL MEMBERS AND MISTER CHAIR
THIS MEASURES ON OPPOSED AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CULTURAL PLEASE STONE BY STONE
I CHAO CHAO AYE CHIU DAVIES.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
KALRA I CALLED AYE KILEY. KILEY
AYE MEAN. REYES REYES AYE. THE
BILLS OUT THANK YOU MEMBERS
FLOWTECH SYSTEM FOUR AS ARE TO
SO HUESO. YEAH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MEMBERS SHOULD THE SECOND.
SIMPLY US- THE BILL WOULD TO.
WE'LL CALL THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO COMP. IN THE
REFORMS OUR GUIDE INPUT INCLUDE
IN OP. THESE FOR OF HELP
CALIFORNIA. THE ECONOMY IN THE
COUNTRY THE FIFTH LARGEST IN
THE MOST STATE IN THE FOR. AND
WE SELL A- OUR DIVERSE HERE.
UNFORTUNATELY AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL IS STILL IS. A POINT OF
CONFLICT. AND WE HAVE LAWS
THAT- TARGET CERTAIN ETHNIC
GROUPS- THAT FAVOR CERTAIN
ETHNIC GROUPS INTERNATIONALLY
MORE THAN OTHERS THAT NEEDS TO
CHANGE IN OUR COUNTRY I LOVE
MANY OF YOU ARE AWARE THAT OUR
HISTORY IN OUR COUNTRY. THE
FIRST IMMIGRATION LAWS THE VERY
FIRST LAW THAT WAS EVER PASSED
BY CONGRESS ÒUALLY
TARGETED AT NATIVE AMERICANS.
THAT TOOK AWAY THEIR BELIEVE IT
OR NOT THEY WERE DECLARED-
FOREIGNERS. THAT WAS VERY FIRST
LAW THE SECOND LAW. WAS DE OF
DIRECTED AT AFRICAN AMERICANS
AND BASICALLY SAID THAT THEY
COULD NOT COME TO THIS COUNTRY
IN A IN ESSENCE. WAS WAS-
INFLUENTIAL AND CURBING. THE
ILLEGAL SAFER THEY'VE TRIED BUT-
IT ALSO- WAS LAW DIRECTED AT
THEM AND- IT JUST SEEMS THAT
EVERY TIME IN AMERICA WE HAVE A
PROBLEM. WITH PEOPLE OF CERTAIN
RELIGIONS OR CULTURES OR
ETHNICITIES WE WANT TO CREATE A
LAW BANNING THEM OR CONTROLLING
THEM OR ELIMINATING THEM AND
THAT'S JUST SOMETHING THAT IS
NOT SERVED OUR COUNTRY WELL
OVER THE HISTORY. AND IT'S BEEN
JUST A CAUSE FOR THE CREATION
GANGS AND VIOLENCE AND
DISSENSION AND HATRED. AND
THAT'S JUST SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE TO CHANGE ABOUT AMERICA.
AND THIS BILL IN PARTICULAR IS
MODELED AFTER YEARS OF WORK IN
THE LEGISLATURE SINCE I MEAN
THIS CAME BACK- WENT GOES BACK
AS FAR AS WHEN OBAMA WAS
PRESIDENT AND WE WERE TRYING TO
CREATE- A SUGGESTION TO THE-
THE- THE CONGRESS ON HOW TO
APPROPRIATELY. REFORM THE
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM AND THIS IS
KIND OF A GOD GUIDE TO HOW TO
DO THAT WERE SENATE HOPEFULLY
SENDING THIS TO WASHINGTON. IN
AN EFFORT THAT THEY'LL ACT AND
WILL ACTUALLY DO SOMETHING. TO
CREATE A SYSTEM THAT CREATES A
PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP AND A
MORE OF A HUMANE WAY TO DEAL
WITH THE PEOPLE THAT ARE.
ATTEMPTING TO COME TO THIS
COUNTRY WHICH IS A BEACON OF
FREEDOM AND OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
REST OF THE WORLD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR I HAVE ONE
WITNESS LISTED IN SUPPORT WHO'S
WITH US ON THE TELEPHONE SILVA.
FROM IMPERIAL VALLEY. ARE YOU
WITH US. CORRECT GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN STONE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR LETTING ME SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF DEATH R. TO CALLING
FOR THE STATE GOVERNMENT ACT
AND IMPLEMENT COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION REFORM. MY NAME IS
SILVA I'M A STUDENT LEADER FOR
IMPROVE A CALL NOW IN THE PAST
THE TRANSFER YOU TO BERKELEY.
MY COMMUNITY CALL. SYSTEM
COMPLETION BUT IS OVER NINETY
PER. THAT IMPACTS. BECAUSE OF
THE SCHOOL TO THE BORDER. WE
JUST. THANK A NEGATIVE ATTACKS
OF DELAYED IMMIGRATION. DELETED
MY P. IN THE INVOLVED IN OUR
SCHOOL AND OUR COMMUNITY. I'M
HERE TO SPEAK ON OWN IN MY
POCKET. BECAUSE IN THE SMALL OF
MY OF TIME. AT ASPEN IN
LEADERSHIP ROLE. I HAVE HEARD
MANY FRUSTRATING AND TRY STORY
BERMAN DOT IS DOING THIS WHOLE
ARE TWICE TO WHICH- TO
EDUCATION ASPIRATIONS. THAT'D
MAKE THE VOICELESS BALLIA. IN A
HACKER FRIENDS ME THAT I DON'T
FEEL FOR THE PERTAIN FOR DAMP
THEIR FAMILIES ABLE JUST CARED
TO EVEN BUT OR APPLY. I WAS
BORN IN BRITAIN EARLY FOR AT
ECOLOGICAL. FOR FIVE YEARS. I
REMEMBER REPRESENTING ON MY OWN
PATH TO BECOME A UNITED STATES.
I UNDER. THE PRIVILEGE HOW TO
BE A TO PUT MY GOAL. TO
CONTRIBUTE TO CALIFORNIA AFTER
SCHOOLING AND EDUCATION AND
WORKING HARD TO UPLIFT THEIR
FAMILIES IN THE COMMUNITY IN A
PROFILE. YET YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO
FULLY PARTICIPATE IN OUR
ECONOMY OUR SOCIETY AND OUR
COMMUNITY BECAUSE OF OUTDATED
LEGAL SYSTEMS THAT MAKE THEM
FEEL UNWANTED AND LEFT OUT. I
HOPE THAT THIS BILL IS COMING
MIND YOU ALL OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY THE CALIFORNIA.
ADVOCATE FOR THOSE WHO NEED IT
THE MOST. I OR THE COMMITTEE
REPORT HI. ON YOUR TO AND TO
CULTIVATE MY PEERS IN IMPERIAL
VALLEY COLLEGE HAVE A PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP AND CONTRIBUTED
THEIR PART TO OUR COUNTRY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I SEE NO
ONE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO WANT TO DO TO SIGN STR TO
USE ANYONE OF THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR S. J.
R. TO. Q. IF YOU WEREN'T A PART
OF AND J. R. QUEUE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
AND THEN ZERO FEAR IN SUPPORT
OF S. J. R. Q. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE OF FORTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE FORTY FOUR DO YOU
HAVE A SON YOU. OKAY YOU HAVE
TO RE QUEUE UP HE'D LIKE TO
SPEAK. IN SUPPORT OF THE S. A.
R. Q. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTING QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU I DO NOT HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION LISTED I SEE NO ONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION IS OR ANYONE OF THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WE JOKE
ALLIANCE FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO
STR TO. GIVEN OPPOSITION UP AS
J. R. TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN THERE
UP IN OPPOSITION OF S. J. R.
TO. EDUCARE WE HAVE NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION AT THE TIME. THANK
YOU BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OPERATE YOU MAY CLOSE
THE LINES. FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. MISTER KALRA. THANK
YOU- THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU SENATOR FROM THIS
FORWARD- I HAVE A RESOLUTION
THAT IS LIKELY NOT TO BE TAKEN
UP FOR A VOTE OF REGARDING-
IT'S SORT OF MORE DIRECT IN
TERMS THE CONDUCT OF ICE AND-
ICE'S ROLE- IN IN TERRORIZING
OUR COMMUNITIES IN BECOMING A
ROGUE- THE- ARM. OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- UNDER. NO IT'S
BIPARTISAN UNDER BOTH
DEMOCRATIC AND REPUBLICAN
ADMINISTRATIONS WE'VE SEEN THAT
KIND OF CONDUCT- AND I
APPRECIATE THIS RESOLUTION
BECAUSE ONCE AGAIN IT'S CALLING
US THING I THINK WE'VE CALLED
ON FOR A VERY LONG TIME. WHICH
IS COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF IMMIGRANTS I TO
OUR STATE TO OUR NATION- I JUST
SEE IT AND IT WILL CERTAINLY BE
IN THE SUPPORTING IT I JUST
HOPE THAT- YOU KNOW THIS IS A
WEIRD KIND OF. WE'RE RUNNING IN
CIRCLES ALL THE TIME IT COMES
IMMIGRATION REFORM BECAUSE DC
AND ESPECIALLY IF- YOU KNOW
ESPECIALLY IF. DEMOCRATS ARE
ARE WILLING TO GET RID OF THE
FILIBUSTER IT JUST SEEMS LIKE
YOU KNOW PEOPLE WILL TALK ABOUT
IT MORE AND- NOTHING WILL
HAPPEN AND SO I'M HOPING AT
LEAST GIVEN THE FACT THAT AS A
STATE. THAT WE HAVE THE
INFLUENCE AND WAIT THAT WE DO.
THAT AT LEAST MAKING THE
STATEMENT ONCE AGAIN- THAT- YOU
KNOW IMMIGRANTS MATTER- HAS
SOMETIME BACK BUT IN THE
MEANTIME I THINK WE DEFINITELY
HAVE TO LOOK AT OUR
INTERACTIONS WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF BILLS I
THINK FALL UNDER THE WIDER
UMBRELLA OF WHAT YOU'RE CALLING
FOR BOTH IN TERMS OF.
TERMINOLOGY THAT'S USING TERMS
INTERACTIONS YOU KNOW WITH OUR
SUMMER CREEL'S VISION ACT AND
HOW WE INTERACT. WITH ICE AND
SO- WITH THIS PARTICULAR
RESOLUTION I HOPE THAT THAT WE
CAN. REALLY PUSH THE TYPES OF
VERY DIRECT POLICY INTERACTION
OR POLICY LEGISLATION AND
INTERACTING WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- THAT ACTUALLY LEADS
TO TREATING- ARE IMMIGRANTS
MORE DIGNITY. SO I JUST OF.
THEM I GUESS PART OF MY
FRUSTRATION BECAUSE- YOU KNOW
WE SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
COMMUNITIES AND- IT'S LIKE WE
TALK A LOT ABOUT IT THE
QUESTION IS WHAT ARE WE GONNA
DO ABOUT IT AND I THINK THIS
PLAYS OUT. IN A WIDE MENU OF
OPTIONS OF THINGS. THAT WE CAN
DO AND THINGS THAT WE SHOULD BE
CALLING FOR. THANK YOU THREATS.
THANK CENTER FOR THIS I- AYE
PRE THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MAINTAINING THE FAMILY
STRUCTURE A PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP AND ALSO THE DUE
PROCESS FOR ALL OF OUR
IMMIGRANTS AND I THINK THAT
HAVING THOSE THREE PARTS IN
YOUR RESOLUTION IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THE PATHWAY TO-
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN WAITING
FOR YEARS- I THINK IT'S CLEAR
THAT THESE ARE CALIFORNIA'S
VALUES. I THINK ALL POLLS
INDICATE THAT THIS IS EXACTLY
WHAT CALIFORNIA VALUES ARE AND
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THE DAY
WHEN IT BECOMES AMERICA'S
VALUES AND THAT CONGRESS ACTS
ON IT THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
RIGHT SIGNALED CENTER YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I JUST WANNA. I JUST WANT TO
REMIND PEOPLE THAT LOOK THE
COMMENT I HEAR THE MOST IS
THAT- PEOPLE SUPPORT
IMMIGRATION AS LONG AS THEY
FOLLOW THE LAW AND COME IN
LEGALLY. AND THAT IS SAID IN A
CONTEXT WHERE IT'S ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE. TO COME IN LEGALLY
BECAUSE OFTENTIMES IT TAKES AS
FAR AS FIFTEEN YEARS. TO GO
THROUGH THE LEGALIZATION
PROCESS AND- IF YOU'RE IN A
FOREIGN COUNTRY. OFTEN OF
SEEKING EITHER ASYLUM. OR
SEEKING ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY.
FIFTEEN YEARS IS JUST UNTENABLE-
ONE MY FATHER CAME TO UNITED
STATES IN NINETEEN FORTY NINE
HE CROSSED LEGALLY AT THE
BORDER GOVERNOR OF PERMIT. AND
HE DECIDED IN NINETEEN. FIFTY
TO THAT HE WANT TO BECOME A
CITIZEN IT TOOK HIM A FEW
MONTHS TO BECOME CITIZEN.
NINETEEN FIFTY TWO. AND- IT
TOOK MONTHS. AND IT IT'S A HARD
DECISION FOR- PEOPLE TO COME
FROM ANOTHER COUNTRY TO SAY I'M
GOING TO CHANGE MY SERVICE ON
THIS SHIP. BUT IN THAT TIME MY
FATHER WAS A VERY PRODUCTIVE
MEMBER. OF THE OF THE UNITED
STATES HE WAS HE BECAME A
BUSINESS NOT A VERY SUCCESSFUL
BUSINESS OWNER. HE BECAME A
LEADER IN THE COMMUNITY. AND. A
VERY OF- AND PART OF OUR
COMMUNITY OF COURSE OUR FAMILY
WE WERE ALL BORN HERE AND WE
ALSO ARE ALSO PROUD TO BE
AMERICAN CITIZENS AND PART OF
THIS WONDERFUL COUNTRY. AND
THAT THAT SHOULD BE A PROCESS
THAT SHOULD BE. EASIER TO
NAVIGATE THAN HAVING TO WAIT
TEN FIFTEEN YEARS AND SO.
HOPEFULLY WE COULD AT LEAST AT
SOME POINT COUNT FOR THE DROP
IN DHAKA THERE ALREADY IN OUR
COUNTRY. PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF
OUR SOCIETY ABIDING BY THE LAW
AND TRYING TO THE STATE
TOGETHER WITH THEIR FAMILIES TO
SEEK OPPORTUNITY AT THE VERY
LEAST. WE SHOULD ACCOUNT FOR
THEM TO START- TO PASS A
REFORM. THAT WILL SUCCESSFULLY
INCORPORATE THEM- LEGALLY INTO
OUR SOCIETY SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND THE MOTION IS THAT THE
RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CHOW. CHOW I CHIU. DAVIES AB
SNOW GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN. HOLDEN I KALRA KALRA
AYE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN
PREVIOUS- REYES AYE SMITH. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
BRINGS US TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SB FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT SENATOR
JONES. ONE SHERMAN. FOR GERMAN
MEMBERS IT'S AN HONOR TO BE
BACK ON THE GREEN CARPET AND-
VISITING TO YOU TODAY SB FIVE
SEVENTY EIGHT. WHICH CAR FIVE
THE CONSERVATORSHIP PROCEEDINGS
UNDER THE LETTERMAN BEATRICE
SHORT ACT ARE TO BE HELD IN
CLOSED COURT UNLESS THE SUBJECT
OF THE PETITION. DEMANDS IT TO
BE PUBLIC. SORTS INVERSES
SUPERIOR COURT HOLDS LPS
CONSERVATORSHIP PROCEEDINGS ARE
INHERENTLY NON PUBLIC DESPITE
THIS LEGAL PRECEDENT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR FOUND
THAT SOME COURTS CONTINUE TO
HEAR THESE SINCE THE
PROCEEDINGS IN OPEN COURT. THIS
PUTS BOTH INDIVIDUALS
CONFIDENTIAL MEDICAL
INFORMATION AND THEIR PERSONAL
REPUTATION AT RISK. THE STATE
AUDITOR'S FINDINGS MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT COURTS NEED MORE
EXPLICIT DIRECTION IN ORDER TO
STANDARDIZE CONSERVATIVE
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS ACROSS THE
STATE. SB FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT
SECURES THE PRIVACY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS BY ONLY ALLOWING
THE SUBJECT OF THE PROCEEDING
TO DEMAND IT TO BE PUBLIC.
HOWEVER THIS BILL STILL ALLOWS
OTHER PARTIES TO REQUEST A
HEARING TO BE PUBLIC IF A JUDGE
FINDS A PUBLIC INTEREST
OUTWEIGHS THE SUBJECTS PRIVACY
INTEREST. FOR THE MORE CONTINUE
TO WORK ON LANGUAGE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
WE ALL WANT WHAT IS BEST FOR
THE CONSERVATIVE. I HAVE
WITNESSES ON THE LINE FROM THE
DEPRESSION AND BIPOLAR SUPPORT
ALLIANCE WHO CAN SHARE THE
IMPORTANT ROLE PRIVACY PLEASE
WHEN DISCUSSING SENSITIVE
MEDICAL INFORMATION. THANK YOU
STRUCTURE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND SO I HAVE ONE WITNESS
LISTED PAUL SIMONS WITH US ON
THE TELEPHONE ARE YOU WITH US.
I AM GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
SENATE COMMITTEE MEMBERS HI MY
NAME'S PUL SIMONS REPRESENTS
THE DEPRESSION AND BIPOLAR
SUPPORT ALLIANCE IN CALIFORNIA.
D. D. SA. EDSA IS THE GREETING
CARE DIRECTED NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION FUNCTIONS THINK
PRIMARILY ON THE TWO MOST
PREVALENT MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS. DEPRESSION AND
BIPOLAR DISORDER WHICH AFFECTS
MORE THAN TWENTY ONE MILLION
AMERICANS. ACCOUNT 490% OF THE
NATION'S SUICIDES EVERY YEAR
AND COST TWENTY THREE BILLION
IN LOST WORK DAYS AND OTHER
WORKPLACE ISSUES. EPSA
CALIFORNIA HERE SO IT ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION. FOR CALIFORNIA
BASED CHAPTERS. SB FIVE SEVEN
IT WOULD REQUIRE A HEARING HELD
UNDER LOOK AT FACTS BE
PRESUMPTIVELY CLOSED TO THE
PUBLIC BUT WOULD AUTHORIZE YOU
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS THE SUBJECT
OF THE PROCEEDINGS DEMAND THAT
THE PUBLIC HEARING. AND HEARING
THE PUBLIC AND BE HELD IN A
PLACE IN THE FALL SUITABLE FOR
TENNIS BY THE PUBLIC. THE DVSA
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTS LEGISLATION
GIVING PRIVACY TO THOSE WHO ARE
SUBJECT TO HEARING ON YOUR LPS
AND THE RIGHT. TO OPEN THE
HEARING TO THE PUBLIC. I A
PAYROLL ORGANISER OF MENTAL
HEALTH CONSUMER WHICH- SUPPORT
PRIVACY. AND PARTICULARLY SELF
DETERMINATION. FOR THOSE WITH
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES.
PRIVACY AND CONFIDENTIALITY
CONFIDENTIALITY ARE HALLMARKS
OF HEALTHCARE AND THEIR CORE
INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS WE WOULD LIKE
WE WOULD ALL LIKE TO KEEP OUR
PERSONAL AFFAIRS BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS. IN THE CASE OF MENTAL
ILLNESS PUBLIC AIRING. OF
INVOLUNTARY COMMITMENT
PROCEEDING SUBSTANTIALLY
INCREASE THE POTENTIAL FOR
INCREASED STIGMA. HAVING A
HEARING PLACE IN PUBLIC VIEW
AGAINST THE WISHES OF THE
SUBJECT THE CLERK ON DUTY
STRUCTURES ON THE SUBJECT OF
THE HEARING POSSIBLY INCITING A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS AND
POSSIBLY LEADING TO
INAPPROPRIATE COMMITMENTS. ON
THE OTHER HAND KEEPING HEARING
HADN'T HEARING HIDDEN FROM
OTHERS AGAINST THE WISHES OF
THE SUBJECT COULD ALSO BE A
STRESSOR BY INCREASING FEELINGS
OF ISOLATION AND HELPLESSNESS
THEY'RE ALREADY EXTREMELY
FRAGILE. INDIVIDUAL THE BILL
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE INDIVIDUAL
CONDUCTING A HEARING TO.
ENCOURAGE REQUEST BY ANOTHER
PARTY TO PROCEEDINGS MAKE THE
CURRENT PUBLIC IF THEY FIND
THAT THE PUBLIC INTEREST IS IN
AN OPEN HEARING CLEARLY
OUTWEIGHS THE INDIVIDUALS
INTERESTED IN PRIVACY NOW WE
RECOGNIZE THERE MAY BE
INSTANCES WHERE THE PUBLIC
INTEREST MIGHT SEEM TO
OUTWEIGH. THAT INTEREST IN
PRIVACY BUT AS THE SUBJECT OF
THE HEARING HAS RIGHTS RIGHTS
TO BE PROTECTED NOT JUST AN
INTEREST AND WE DO TRUST THAT
THE EVIDENCE TO OVERRULE THE
SUBJECTS WISHES WILL BE
COMPELLING. INDEED I THANK
SENATOR FOR SUPPORTING RIGHTS
OF THE MENTALLY ILL AT RISK.
ASK YOUR ZIP OF THIS IMPORTANT
BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU
THIRTY ONE IN THE HEARING WHO'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT. SEEING NONE
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEE NON OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO'D LIKE
TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE
SEVENTY EIGHT WE ARE TAKING
NAME AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE SEVEN EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
AND THEN ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE NO OPPOSITION
LISTED IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
SEVENTY EIGHT. SIGNALED THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN ALLIANCE FOR ANYONE WHO'D
LIKE TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO
SB FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT. KILLED
HERE IN OPPOSITION OF FIVE
SEVENTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION OF SB. FIVE
SEVEN EIGHT. I'M NOT SURE WE
HAVE NO OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. RIGHT THANK YOU ARE
PRETTY MAY CLOSE THE LIGHTS ON
WHEN TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. MR TRUMP THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HIS CHAIR I'M GOING
TO ABSTAIN FROM VOTING TODAY
AND URGED THE TWO SIDES TO
CONTINUE NEGOTIATION- I HAD A
CHANCE TO TALK WITH THE LATE
OPPOSITION YESTERDAY THE
PRESIDING JUDGE OF THE SUPERIOR
COURT AND I'M- SYMPATHETIC TO
HIS- ARGUMENTS SO AND I ALSO
HAD A CHANCE TO REVIEW THE
MATERIALS AS WELL AS THE VIDEO-
D. N. I LEARN A LOT MORE ABOUT
THE- THIS THE HOLLYWOOD MENTAL
HEALTH COURT HOUSING COURT
ROOM- IN THAT IT YOU KNOW THE
COURT ROOM IS VERY UNIQUE AND
IN MANY REGARDS AND- FIRST OF
ALL IT IS IT IS- THE ONLY. ARM
COURT ROOM IN CALIFORNIA THAT
DEALS EXCLUSIVELY WITH MENTAL
HEALTH CASES. I HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND IT IS ALSO VERY
CENTRALIZED IN THE SENSE THAT-
IT COMBINES A LOT OF THE
EXPERTISE ALL UNDER ONE ROOF.
UP SO. NOW THEY HANDLE A LOT OF
CASES UP OVER THE YEARS I THINK
THE AVERAGE IS LIKE SIXTY CASES
A DAY. AND YOU KNOW A LOT MORE
THAN OTHER COURT ROOMS IN IN
THE STATE. AND AS A RESULT- DAY
YOU KNOW I THINK. COMPLYING
WITH THE TERMS OF THIS LAW.
WOULD BASICALLY CHANGE THE ON A
DYNAMIC THE CENTRALIZATION.
MODELS THAT THEY CURRENTLY
HOUSE IN THAT THE STATE WOULD
HAVE TO CONTACT YOU KNOW SEEK A
SEPARATE COURT ROOM TO HANDLE
SOME OF THESE CASES THAT THEY
CURRENTLY HOUSE. WHICH WILL
BREAK UP THAT CENTRALIZATION
MODEL A WHICH IS VERY WHICH HAS
PROVEN TO BE VERY EFFECTIVE.
AND IN FACT THE CALL AT THE
CROWN JEWEL YOU KNOW UP OF THIS
PARTICULAR- CASE IS SO. CALM SO
I LIKE I SAID I'M A LITTLE
SYMPATHETIC TO THE ARGUMENTS.
AND I AM. GOOD ASK PERHAPS. YOU
KNOW. YOU KNOW THE TWO SIDES TO
CONTINUE NEGOTIATIONS RUSSIA
AND I THINK THERE'S A WAY TO
GET THERE AND IF NOT YOU KNOW I
KNOW THAT THEY SUGGESTED SOME
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL AS WELL
R. IF THOSE MEMBERS DON'T WORK
AND I THINK PERHAPS WHAT YOU
COULD DO IS TO PROBABLY.
IMPLEMENT SOME KIND OF A DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION POP LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL SO THAT THEY WOULD BE
ALLOWED MORE TIME TO CAN
IMPLEMENT YOUR LAW AND I THINK
DEFINITELY DOABLE THING TO DO
SO WITH THAT I'M JUST GONNA
ABSTAINED FROM FROM LOOKING
TACKLE BUT I HOPE TO BE ABLE TO
A VOTE OF FORD CAUGHT ON FLY.
THANK YOU. THANKS THANK YOU
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR BRINGING-THIS FORWARD I AM AWARE THAT
THERE IS A COURT IN LOS ANGELES
THAT IS IN OPPOSITION. THE
PROBLEM IS WE HAVE A CASE OUT
THERE THE SORENSON CASE. WHICH
DICTATES HOW THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO RUN THAT THAT HEARING WERE
RUN THAT COURTROOM AND THEY ARE
FROM WHAT I CAN SEE NOT IN
COMPLIANCE WITH IT. SO I DON'T
DISAGREE WITH THE RULING OF THE
COURTS NOR WITH WHAT YOUR BILL
IS TRYING TO DO. AND ACTUALLY I
WOULD ENCOURAGE LOS ANGELES TO
THINK A LITTLE BIT HARDER ABOUT
HOW THEY COME INTO COMPLIANCE.
WITH WHAT IS IN FACT EXISTING
LAW. TO WITH THAT SENATOR YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND TO MISTER CHOW'S
CONCERNS- OF COURSE- WE'RE
GONNA CONTINUE WE WE'VE HAD
VERY VIGOROUS CONVERSATIONS
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS-
THEY'VE INVITED ME TO COME DOWN
AND TAKE A TOUR OF THE COURTS
WHICH I INTEND TO DO WE HAD IT
ON THE BOOKS BUT- THINGS GOT
CHANGED UP SO- WE'RE GONNA BE
GOING DOWN THERE AND- YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY BEFORE THEN THE
SESSION TAKE A LOOK AT HOW THEY
DO THINGS WE WILL CONTINUE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. AT THE END
OF THE DAY I THINK ALL OF US
AGREE THAT THE NUMBER ONE. MOST
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THIS BILL
IS THE CONSERVATIVE E. AND
PROTECTING THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
AND THEIR PRIVACY. AND SO
THAT'S WHAT WE'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK TOWARDS THANK YOU ASK FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
CHOLERA PLEASE STAND BY STONE
AYE CHAU. CHIU DAY. DAVEY I
CONSULT. GONZALEZ I HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE KALRA KALRA AYE
KILEY KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
RIESS SMITH. SMITH HI THANK YOU
THE BILLS THAT FIGURES SHERMAN
THANK YOU MEMBERS APPRECIATE
YOURS- YOU'RE OUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR LEYVA THAT BRINGS
US TO ITEM NUMBER SIX SB. THREE
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS IT'S NICE TO SEE
EVERYBODY. I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
ALL OF YOU BUT I FEEL LIKE IT'S
ALREADY JUNE AND WERE ALREADY
SWITCHING HOUSES AND PRESENTING
OUR BILLS IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S
GONE VERY FAST. ALL RIGHT I
WOULD FIRST LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON
THIS BILL AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS LISTED ON PAGE NINE
OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATE BILL
THREE THREE ONE ALSO KNOWN AS A
SAM SNOW MORE ACT EXPANDS THE
PROHIBITION ON NONDISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS NDAS TO COVER A
CIVIL SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS
INVOLVING ALL FORMS OF
HARASSMENT OR DISCRIMINATION.
THIS BILL ALSO EXPANDS THE
PROHIBITION ON OVERLY BROAD
CONFIDENTIALITY AND NON
DISPARAGEMENT CLAUSES IN
EMPLOYMENT AGREEMENTS TO COVER
WORKERS WHO ARE REQUIRED TO
FIND THESE TYPES OF CLASSES AS
PART OF A SEVERANCE PACKAGE
AGREEMENT. AS MANY OF YOU MAY
REMEMBER I AUTHORED AND THEN
GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED SB EIGHT
TWENTY ALSO KNOWN AS A STAND
ACT IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
SB EIGHT TWENTY SPECIFICALLY
BANNED NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS
IN CASES OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND SEXUAL
DISCRIMINATION. IMPORTANTLY THE
STAND ACT ALSO ALLOWS THE
CLAIMANT TO REQUEST
CONFIDENTIALITY IF THEY SO
CHOOSE. IN PASSING THIS
HISTORIC LAW THE LEGISLATURE
RECOGNIZE THAT SETTLEMENTS
SECRET SETTLEMENTS WERE HELPING
TO PERPETRATE HOSTILE WORK
ENVIRONMENTS BY ALLOWING
COMPLAINTS TO BE SWEPT UNDER
THE RUG. OF COURSE SECRET
SETTLEMENTS PLACE MUCH A ROLE
IN PERPETRATING WORKPLACE
DISCRIMINATION HARASSMENT AND
BIAS BASED ON RACE ETHNICITY
SEXUAL ORIENTATION AGE
DISABILITY AND RELIGION.
BECAUSE HERE TO COMPLAINTS ARE
KEPT SECRET AND THOSE WHO RAISE
THE COMPLAINTS ARE EFFECTIVELY
SILENCED. MEMBERS IT IS
UNACCEPTABLE FOR ANY EMPLOYER
TO TRY TO SILENCE WORKERS
BECAUSE HERE SHE WAS THE VICTIM
OF ANY TYPE OF HARASSMENT OR
DISCRIMINATION. THE SILENCE NO
MORE ACT WILL EMPOWER SURVIVORS
TO SPEAK OUT IF THEY SO WISH SO
THE PERPETRATORS CAN BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE WE CAN HOPEFULLY
PREVENT ABUSERS FROM CONTINUING
TO TORMENT AND ABUSE OTHER
WORKERS. WORKERS SHOULD ALWAYS
BE ABLE TO SPEAK OUT AGAINST
THIS DEPLORABLE BEHAVIOR IN THE
WORKPLACE WELL TO DEMAND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TO RIP
FUTURE ABUSES. BY PERPETRATORS
HERE WITH ME TODAY REMOTELY TO
SHARE HER OWN PERSONAL STORY
AND EXPERIENCE IS THE FORMA AS
SOMEWHAT. AS WELL AS PETER
RECKON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR I DO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES LISTED PETER BROKEN.
AND IF YOU'RE A SOBRE FROM
RECEIVED BOTH WITH US ON THE
TELEPHONE PETER ROQUAN. HI GOOD-MORNING- AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS RICK AND- I'M AN
EMPLOYMENT ATTORNEY IN OAKLAND-
OVER THE COURSE OF MY CAREER. I
REPRESENTED EMPLOYERS PUBLIC
ENTITIES EMPLOYEES IN A WIDE
VARIETY OF EMPLOYMENT DISPUTES.
REVIEWING AND NEGOTIATING
SETTLEMENTS AND SEVERANCE
AGREEMENT IS A SIGNIFICANT PART
OF MY PRACTICE- I'M HERE TODAY.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CLINTON LAWYERS ASSOCIATION AND
ADMITTED THE SELLER'S ATTORNEY.
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF SB THREE
THREE ONE. BUT WHILE NON
DISPARAGEMENT CLAUSES AND
SEVENTY GRAMS HAVE BECOME MORE
COMMON. OVER THE LAST FEW
DECADES- IN MY VIEW THEY HAVE
LITTLE SOCIAL VALUE I'M JUST.
IF I CAN'T USE ONE EXAMPLE- WHY
SHOULD CALIFORNIANS LOOKING FOR
A SAFE PLACE TO WORK. THE
UNABLE TO GATHER INFORMATION ON
GLASS DOOR BECAUSE FORMER
EMPLOYEES ARE TERRIFIED OF
PUBLICLY SAYING TRUTHFUL THINGS.
ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCE OF
HARASSMENT OR DISCRIMINATION.
IN FACT RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
THE AVAILABILITY OF NON
ANONYMOUS INFORMATION ON
GLASSDOOR ACTUALLY INCREASED
AFTER SB EIGHT TWENTY.
RESTRICTED THE USE OF SECRET
SETTLEMENTS I UNDERSTAND THAT
OPPONENTS OF SB THREE THREE ONE
ARGUE THAT THIS BILL WILL
DISCOURAGE EMPLOYERS FROM
PAYING SEVERANCE TO WORKERS A
SIMILAR ACCUSATION WAS MADE
ABOUT SB EIGHT TWENTY IT WAS
SAID THAT IF YOU TAKE AWAY THE
NDA PARTIES WILL BE ABLE TO
SETTLE CASES. AND THAT HAS NOT
HAPPENED. WHEN AND THE AGE WERE
TAKEN OFF THE TABLE THEY JUST
NO LONGER BECAME A PART OF
NEGOTIATION. WHAT WE KNOW IS
THAT THE TRUE VALUE IN A
SEVERANCE AGREEMENT IT'S THE
RELEASE PLANE'S NOT SECRECY
PROVISION. A RELEASE AVOID THE
POSSIBILITY OF MONTHS OR YEARS
OF LITIGATION. AND THE
POTENTIAL OF AN ADVERSE
JUDGMENT. FURTHERMORE IT ARGUES
THAT THE SECRECY PROVISIONS ARE
EFFECTIVELY UNENFORCEABLE NOW
IN MY THIRTY YEARS OR MORE OF
LAW PRACTICE THE ONLY
ENFORCEMENT ACTION I'M AWARE
OF. WHAT DONALD TRUMP'S CLAIM
AGAINST ARMY DANIELS. NO
RATIONAL EMPLOYERS TO SPEND
FORCING NON DISPARAGEMENT
CLAUSE BECAUSE DOING SO SIMPLY
BE PUBLICIZED. THE ALLEGED
COMMENTS. THE TRUE VALUE IN
THESE PROVISIONS THE AMERICAN
CERAMIC BACKED AWAY TWENTY
MILLION EMPLOYEES AND THANKS
SILENCE EVEN ABOUT UNLAWFUL
DISCRIMINATION OR HARASSMENT.
THIS NOT ONLY HURTS WORKERS IN
ENDANGERED PUBLIC SAFETY IN THE
PUBLIC- AND DOES A DISSERVICE
TO LAW ABIDING EMPLOYERS WHO
ARE COMPETING. FOR EMPLOYEES
AND THE JOB MARKET SO ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CUENTA
LURKING SUFFICIENT URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE YES ON SB
THREE THREE ONE. THANK YOU AND
WE ALSO HAVE MISSISSAUGA. THANK
YOU- CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY TODAY MY
ENTIRE CAREER HAS BEEN ATTACKED
PUBLIC POLICY OFFICIAL ENGAGING
WITH OFFICES LIKE YOURS ON
BEHALF OF COMPANIES LIKE GOOGLE
FACEBOOK AND ENSURE AT MY LAST
WORK TRIP BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
WHAT THE DEFEAT SEPARATE THAT
WORK ON HELP WITH THAT I LAGGED
ON HELP WITH INFORMATION. THAT
WOULD DAYS BEFORE PINTEREST
LAWYERS PRESENTED ME WITH A
HIGHLY RESTRICTIVE
NONDISCLOSURE AND NON
DISPARAGEMENT AGREEMENT MEANT
THINKING IF I WENT ABOUT THE
RACE AND GENDER DISCRIMINATION
AND RETALIATION CLAIM I'D
RAISED OVER THE PREVIOUS YEAR
WHEN I DECIDED TO COMEFORWARD
PUBLICLY I ALONG WITH THE
FORMER COLLEAGUE NAMED ERICA
ISSUED THE BANKS DID SO WITH
THE KNOWLEDGE THAT WOULD BE
COVERED FOR DISCLOSURES RELATED
TO GENDER BASED DISCRIMINATION
UNDER ACT BE EIGHT TWENTY.
WHICH I'M SO GRATEFUL TO TENER
LEYVA FOR OFFERING DURING THE
MEETING WITH MATT UNFORTUNATELY
AS A BLACK WOMAN I CANNOT
SEPARATE MY RATES FROM MY
GENDER WHICH MEANT THAT
MENTIONS OF THE RACE
DISCRIMINATION I AND DEREK
COULD RESULT IN LEGAL
RETALIATION NO WORKERS SHOULD
BE IN A POSITION WHERE PART OF
THEIR IDENTITY EVELYN COVERED
WHEN IT COMES TO DISPOSING
UNLAWFUL TREATMENT. AND YEARS
LIKE THE ONE I HAD NO CHOICE
BUT TO SIGN OUR USED BY
COMPANIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT WORKERS A
FUNDAMENTALLY AMERICAN SPEECH
RIGHT HOW MANY WORKERS CAN
REFUSE TO SIGN THESE AGREEMENTS
AT THE EXTENT THAT THE INCOME
OR HEALTH INSURANCE FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
WHAT'S WORSE IS THAT COMPANIES
DON'T EVEN NEED TO AND YET THE
KEY PROPRIETARY INFORMATION SAY
THAT INFO IS ALREADY PROTECTED
USING IT THE CONFIDENTIALITY
AGREEMENT EMPLOYEES MUST SIGN
WHEN THEY'RE HIRED ADDITIONALLY
AS PETER MENTIONED LISA CLOSETS
AND SEVERANCE AGREEMENTS ENSURE
COMPANIES DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT LITIGATION FROM OUTGOING
EMPLOYEES. FINALLY THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO BENEFIT THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY BY INCREASING
TRANSPARENCY FOR SHAREHOLDERS
I'M. NOT THE INDIVIDUAL SPEAK
UP AND THAT'S- CAPTAIN OF ABOUT
MISSED AT THE- PLAN WHICH THEY
HAVE A- STAKE. WE SHOULD ARGUE
AGAIN THAT. LET IT PLAY. A LOT
ABOUT THOSE AND I. THAT ABOUT
THE BILL STYLE. SB THIRTY ONE
AND THIS GUY. HER AND ASSAULT
BUT MY HOPE IS THAT IT WILL ON
BALLOT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN
WHICH WOULD YOUR FOR A PLEASE.
YEAH SOMEONE DOWN MY AND I'M
HERE AFTER OUR- THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH RIGHT IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE THIRTY ONE. SEEING
NONE AT THEIR MOST TESTIMONY
STATION. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
THOSE WHO'D LIKE TO INDICATE
SUPPORT FOR SB THREE THIRTY
ONE. AND WE'RE TAKING NAMES
AFFILIATED YOU AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FAIR IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY THREE ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO PURE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE THREE ONE. AND WE WILL GO
LINE OF TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. TWENTY SEVEN YOU LEFT
Q. YOU'LL HAVE TO START THE
EURO- ONE ZERO AGAIN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO GO BACK INTO Q. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE THREE ONE THANK YOU.
THANK IN OCTOBER LINE OF FIFTY
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR TERM NUMBERS
CHRISTOPHER SPONSORED POLICY
ADVOCATE WESTERN CINEMA POVERTY
IN STRONG SUPPORTER IS NOT YOU
THINK YOU'RE- THANK YOU AND
NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF FIFTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MARKET
AMERICAN WE HAVE A STRONG
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AN EXTROVERT TO LINE UP OF
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN STANDING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
TRAVIS YOUR CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AN EXTRA LINE OF
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MY NAME IS TO
BE TIME AGAIN I'M A TECH WORKER
IN NINETEEN SUPPORTER OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU AN EXTRA LINE
OF TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CAN
MEMBERS THIS IS JESSICA STENDER
ON BEHALF OF THE COSPONSORED
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES
CALIFORNIANS WARMER CLIMATE
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION AND- KEYED
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU AN
EXTRA LINE OF FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS ERICA
SHIMIZU BONTA FOUNDER SHE FELT
AND FORMER EMPLOYEE AT
PINTEREST AND NINE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB THREE TWO ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN EXTRA
LINE OF THE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AND THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JAN CAUGHT
I AM WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHECK THANK
YOU OPERATOR WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO OPPOSITION I HAVE ONE
OPPOSITION WITNESS LISTED
ACTUALLY HOFFMAN OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ARE YOU WITH US. YES MISTER
CHAIR GO AHEAD PLEASE. THANK
YOU- GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS ACTUALLY HOPPIN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE THIRTY
FIND OUT ABOUT WHAT WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS GENERALLY ABOUT THE
BILL'S LIMITATIONS ON THE USE
OF CONFIDENTIALITY PROVISIONS
AND SEVERANCE AGREEMENTS AND
THE EFFECT THAT THAT MAY HAPPEN
TO YOUR LAWYER'S DECISION
WHETHER TAHQUITZ SEVERANCE AND
ALL. I HAD TODAY I'D LIKE TO
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS ONE
REQUESTED AMENDMENTS- IN THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WE
HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR- IN THE COMMITTEE ABOUT
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL AND THAT
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS RECOGNIZED
THAT THERE WAS A CONCERN THAT
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL COULD
BE INTERPRETED MEAN THAT
EMPLOYEES COULD NOT BE
PREVENTED FROM DISCLOSING HOW
MUCH MONEY THEY RECEIVED AS A
RESULT OF THE SEVERANCE
AGREEMENT SO THE AMOUNT TO THE
SEVERANCE- THIS IS A CONCERN TO
EMPLOYERS- AT THE- COMPARISONS
BETWEEN SEVERANCE AMOUNT COULD
LEAD TO. POTENTIAL RESENTMENT
BETWEEN EMPLOYEES- AND ORGAN
SIMPLER FOR ANY DIFFERENCES
ULTIMATELY COULD ALSO LEAD TO
SOME LEGAL DISPUTES WHICH IS A
BIG PART OF WHAT SEVERANCE
AGREEMENTS ARE REALLY INTENDED
TO POINT OUT THAT ANALYSIS
THEREFORE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE EXPECTED TO QUOTE
CLARIFIED THAT THE AMOUNT OF
THE SEVERANCE PAYMENT MAY BE
KEPT CONFIDENTIAL AS PART OF A
SEPARATE AGREEMENTS. HOWEVER
AND THE ACTUAL LANGUAGE THAT
WILL- WITHIN THE AMENDMENT TO
SUBSECTION II OF THE RELEVANT-
CODES STATE THAT NOTHING
PROHIBITS PROHIBITING
DISCLOSURE OF THE AMOUNT OF THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT NOT A
SEPARATE AGREEMENT I WHEN WE
RACES AFTER COMMITTEE AND WE
AUTHORED SPONSORS DECLINED TO
ACCEPT THAT AMENDMENT BECAUSE
THEY DID NOT BELIEVE THE BILL
AT THE TEMPERATE NOW COULD BE
READ TO PROHIBIT KEEPING THAT
AND THAT CONFIDENTIAL. HOWEVER
WE BELIEVE CLARITY IN STATUTORY
LANGUAGE ABOUT WHAT ALIVE DOES
OR DOES NOT PROHIBIT IT IS
ESSENTIAL FOR EMPLOYERS
ESPECIALLY THOSE SMALL
EMPLOYERS WHO MAY NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO LEGAL COUNSEL- BE
ANALYSIS ACTUALLY FROM THIS
COMMITTEE AGREED WITH THAT AND
I AGREE THAT THE CLARIFICATION
WOULD BE BENEFICIAL AND
RECOMMENDED THAT THIS AMENDMENT
BE CONSIDERED U. S. WAY
TREATABLE CONCERNS THAT
STATUTES NOT BE READ MORE
PROBABLY THAN INTENDED- WE
THEREFORE DO REQUESTED.
PROTECTION EASY AMENDED TO MAKE
CLEAR THAT NOTHING. AND BILL
PRESS. KEEP ME ON MY AND
INTEGRATE BACK- BECAUSE- THANK
YOU. THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM LIKE TO SPEAK ABOUT
THE- OF SB THREE THREE WHAT. I
NO ANYONE ROTORS STATE. SEEING
NONE OPERATOR WHICH ALLIANCE
FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
GET OPPOSITION TO SB THREE
THIRTY ONE WE'RE TAKING NAME
AFFILIATION AND OPPOSITION. YES
IN OPPOSITION AS OF S. B. THREE
THREE ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION OF S. B. THREE
THREE ONE. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THE JERRY
MEMBERS STATE MORTGAGE ON
BEHALF OF THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
WOULD RESPECTFULLY A MINOR
COMMENTS THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING KATIE
HAMPTON WITH A CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED AND
ALIGNER COMMENTS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN MEXICO
LINE OF FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING NUMBERS
CHAIN HOP ON BEHALF OF THE
CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA ALONG YOUR COMMENTS
WITH THE CHAMBERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AN EXTRA LINE OF
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BRIAN
LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION ALIGNING OUR
POSITION WITH THAT OF THE
CHAMBER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU ARE PRETTY
MAY CLOSE THE LINES OF BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. RIGHT SEE NONE SENATOR
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU-
MISTER- CHAIR MEMBERS I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO THANK MS AS- AND
MS SCHMITZ WHO BANKS FOR HAVING
THE COURAGE TO COME FORWARD IF
THIS BILL MAKES IT OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY AND ULTIMATELY
SIGNED INTO LAW BY THE
GOVERNOR. THEY WILL HAVE
CHANGED WORKPLACES IN A
POSITIVE WAY IN THE YEARS TO
COME I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO NOTE
THAT THE COMPANY- THAT WAS
REFERENCED IN THE WITNESS
TESTIMONY HAS NOT MADE PUBLIC
THAT THEY ARE CHANGING THEIR
PRACTICES AND ARE IN FACT NOW
SUPPORTING THIS BILL. SHOWING
THAT EMPLOYERS TRYING TO DO
BETTER BY THEIR WORKERS ARE
BRACING PUBLIC POLICY AND THE
UNDERLYING BILL I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED TO LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE HI
STONE I CHAU HI CHECK OUT CHIU.
DAVIES YEAH DAVIES NO. GONZALEZ
HI GONZALEZ I HOLDEN. HOLDEN
AYE KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
HIGHLY NOTE MAIENSCHEIN RADIUS
FIVE REYES I SMITH SMITH NOW.
THE BILLS OUT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK
YOU SENATOR THAT BRINGS US TO
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN S. B. THREE
SEVENTY FOUR SENATOR MEANT.
THANK YOU JUST DON'T HAVE
PROCEED. PLEASE ENTER YOUR
STONE THANK YOU TO COMMITTEE
STAFF OF AND WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL AND THANK YOU TO THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOW ME TO PRESENT SB THREE
SEVENTY FOUR. WHICH WOULD AMEND
THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PREVENTION ACT TO ADD
REPRODUCTIVE COERCION AS A FORM
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
REPRODUCTIVE COERCION WOULD BE
DEFINED AS CONTROL OVER THE
REPRODUCTIVE ECONOMY OF ANOTHER
THROUGH THREAT OF FORCE OR
INTIMIDATION. DURING THE CALL
THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC MANY OF
US STAYED AT HOME TO TRY TO
KEEP OURSELVES AND OUR FAMILY
SAFE. BUT HOME AS WE KNOW IS
NOT SAFE FOR EVERYONE. THE DATA
IS STILL BEING COLLECTED BUT
ANECDOTALLY IT APPEARS THAT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY SEARCH
IN THE PAST YEAR. THIS INCREASE
IN ABUSE HAS AGAIN HIGHLIGHTED
THE CRITICAL NEED. TO ENSURE
THAT OUR LAWS ACCURATELY
REFLECT AND ADDRESS THE VARIOUS
FORMS THAT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND ABUSE CAN TAKE. LAST YEAR
MY COLLEAGUE IN THE JOINT
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL SENATOR
SUSAN RUBIO EXPANDED THE
DEFINITION OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
TO INCLUDE COERCIVE CONTROL.
THOSE OF US WHO HAVE SOME
FAMILIARITY WITH THE RESEARCH
AND ADVOCACY OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE NOW. THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ISN'T SIMPLY ABOUT ONE
PERSON HITTING OR ABUSING
ANOTHER IT'S ABOUT A CYCLE OF
VIOLENCE AND CONTROL. THAT
CAUSES THE VICTIM OR SURVIVOR
TO BE IN PERPETUAL FEAR. AND
REPRODUCTIVE COERCION IS A KEY
FORM OF ABUSE THAT IS PART OF
THAT CYCLE. EXPANDING ON THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE FROM LAST
YEAR AND BUILDING ON THE WIDE
ARRAY OF RESEARCH AROUND
REPRODUCTIVE COERCION AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. SB THREE
SEVENTY FOUR WOULD CLARIFY THAT
REPRODUCTIVE COERCION IS A FORM
OF COERCIVE CONTROL. WELL MY
WITNESSES WILL PROVIDE A MORE
IN DEPTH EXPLANATION WHAT THIS
MEANS ON A HIGH LEVEL OF THE
STATUTORY LANGUAGE INDICATES
REPRODUCTIVE COERCION. WOULD
INCLUDE USING FORCE OR THE
THREAT OF FORCE TO DO THE
FOLLOWING. EXCESSIVELY AND ON
RECENTLY PRESSURING SOMEONE TO
GET PREGNANT. DELIBERATELY FEAR
INTERFERING WITH CONTRACEPTION
USE OR ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH INFORMATION. AND USING
COERCIVE TACTICS SUCH AS FORCE
WITH THREAT OF FORCE TO CONTROL
OR TEMP TO CONTROL VARIOUS
PREGNANCY OUTCOMES. ALTHOUGH
THE TERM REPRODUCTIVE COERCION
MAY BE UNFAMILIAR TO MANY OF US
THIS ABUSIVE BEHAVIOR IS
UNFORTUNATELY ALL TOO COMMON AS
PART OF THE CYCLE OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. EIGHT TWO THOUSAND
STUDY THAT LOOKED AT FIVE FOR A
FAMILY PLANNING CLINICS
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. FOUNDED
APPROXIMATELY 20% OF DV
SURVIVORS AGES SIXTEEN TO
TWENTY NINE. HAD EXPERIENCED
PREGNANCY COERCION. A TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN STUDY OF FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY SEXUALLY ACTIVE
HIGH SCHOOL FEMALES. FOUND THAT
NEARLY ONE IN EIGHT HAD
EXPERIENCE REPRODUCTIVE
COERCION IN THE PAST THREE
MONTHS. AND THE NATIONAL
HOTLINE INVESTING VIOLENCE
FOUND THAT 25% OF WOMEN. HAD
REPORTED THAT THEIR PARTNER OR
EX PARTNER HAD TRIED TO FORCE
OR PRESSURE THEM TO BECOME
PREGNANT. REPRODUCTIVE COERCION
IS A COMMON FORM OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND YET DESPITE ITS
WIDESPREAD IMPACT. IT REMAINS
UNNAMED IN CALIFORNIA'S LAWS. I
AND THIS BILL WOULD ADDRESS
THAT IT WOULD PROVIDE ACCESS TO
THINGS LIKE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS. AND OTHER
FORMS OF JUDICIAL RELIEF TO
SURVIVORS SEEKING JUSTICE AND
PROTECTION FROM OUR DB LOSS.
THIS BILL WILL SAVE LIVES. I
HAVE WITH ME TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY DAY PROFESSOR JAMES
STOVER. WHO IS THE DIRECTOR OF
UC IRVINE'S DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
LAW CLINIC AND THE INITIATIVE
TO END FAMILY VIOLENCE. AS WELL
AS DR ADAM CROSS HAND.
CROSSWIND AND OBGYN TEACHING AT
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. WHO
HAS FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE
WITNESSING THIS TYPE OF ABUSE.
THANK YOU I DO HAVE THE TWO
WITNESSES LISTED PROFESSOR
STOVER AND DR CROSSLAND
PROFESSOR STOVER. THANK HERE
GOOD MORNING TESTIMONY FAMILY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JAMES
GALLAGHER AND I GOT PRESENTED
TO BE SURVIVORS FOR THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS IN A PROFESSOR AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
IRVINE SCHOOL OF LAW. ON BEHALF
OF THE UC I LIKE ELECTRIC
PILOTS CLINIC IN OUR MANY
CLIENTS WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED
REPRODUCTIVE COERCION. SB THREE
SEVENTY FOUR. THIS IS I WOULD
REQUIRE BECAUSE WE COERCION
NEXT PER. IN HARMFUL AT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WOULD HARM
INCLUDING INCREASED TRANSMITTED
INFECTION I MEAN CAN THE
PREGNANCY AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
INCLUDES HIGH QUALITY FOLLOWING
DISCOLORATION. APPOINTED BODY
IN TRASH. WE PRACTICAL OCEANS
THINK IT'S- PERSON TO ABOUT AND
PROJECTION THANK YOU GUYS
WRITTEN IN MY AND- IN PART
BECAUSE I CAN CERTAINLY. IF HE
REMAINED ON HOLD CALIFORNIA'S
CONNECTED VIOLENCE. PREVENTION
BUT WITH WELL IT'S LARA MEDICAL
SOCIAL WE- WHEN APPARENTLY CAN
CREATE SIXTY WITH THE NEW THEY
FELT WHEN SHE COURAGEOUS ASK
THAT I SHARE HER STORY. WE
SHOULD TO OUR CLINIC CHIU I BE
LOOKING FOR OF THE- FROM HER EX.
INCLUDING FOR BACK THAT LEFT
HER FOR AND BITTEN. THE TO DATE
SHE ALSO COUNTY I SHE WENT BACK
HOME YOU CONDOMS I WOULD ARMS
WE- BUT HE REFUSED AND TOLD HER
JUST PLAIN BE REPORTING
PREGNANT. WE SHE BECAME
PREGNANT I'M GOING INSISTED
THAT SHE HAD BEEN GOING. BUT
SHE DIDN'T WANT THE SHOULDN'T
THAT. INSTEAD GOT A CRITICS.
FOR DIRECT VIOLENCE ORDER.
DURING THE RESTRAINING HERE WE
ARE TESTIFIED ABOUT THAT WE
IRISH. WHAT WE RECOGNIZE AS
EVERY COERCION. DETACHED CAN
LEVINE. SHE ACROSS CUSTOM. THAT
I YOU TALKING ABOUT RIGHT. HI
CALIF ON. I CASH BUT IT HAS SO
OFTEN. HI EXPERIENCE LIVING I'D
MUCH SURVIVE ARE STILL LOCKED
D. NIGHT ONLY SAFETY IN HEALTH.
AND WHY WOULD CAL PM. SIX FIFTY
THREE. EVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DOCTOR CROW THE- THANK YOU
DOWN COMMITTEE ON THE OF DOCTOR
HA AND REPLIED HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS ALIKE MY NAME IS DR
ADAM CROSSMAN MATERNAL FETAL
MEDICINE TELLS SUFFICIENT.
REPRODUCTIVE COERCION IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I'VE SEEN
THROUGHOUT MY CAREER. WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE IN A CLINICAL
SETTING IS WOMEN ASKING FOR
BIRTH CONTROL METHODS THEIR
PARTNERS CAN'T SEE OR KNOW
ABOUT. THE ASK FOR THE
DEPO-PROVERA SHOT A MEDICATION
THAT IS INJECTED ONCE EVERY
THREE MONTHS SO THAT THEIR
PARENTS HAT THEIR PARTNERS
CAN'T THROW AWAY THEIR BIRTH
CONTROL PILLS OR POKE HOLES IN
CONDOMS. THE SPECIFICALLY ASK
FOR THE HORMONE FREE
INTRAUTERINE DEVICE TO GIVE
SOME HEAVIER MORE PAINFUL
PERIODS DESPITE HAVING MULTIPLE
OF LESS PAINFUL CHOICES.
BECAUSE THEY STILL NEED TO HAVE
A PERIOD OTHERWISE THEIR
PARTNER MIGHT SUSPECT THE DEER
USING A CONTRACEPTIVE AND HURT
OR PIZZA. YZERMAN WOMEN WHO GET
TESTED MORE FREQUENTLY FOR
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED
INFECTIONS. BECAUSE OF THEIR
PARTNERS HAVING MULTIPLE OTHER
PARTNERS AND REFUSING TO WEAR A
CONDOM. ON DAYS WHEN WE PERFORM
ABORTIONS THIS LOOKS LIKE
PATIENTS WHO UNDERGO THE
PROCEDURE WITHOUT PAIN
MEDICATION. IF YOU WANT PAIN
MEDICATION YOU NEED A DRIVER TO
DRIVE YOU HOME OUT OF FEAR
THESE PATIENTS HAVE NO FRIENDS
OR FAMILY TO CALL THEY ALSO
CAN'T APPEAR SLEEPY OR ALTERED
FROM MEDICATION WHEN THEIR
PARTNERS COME HOME FOR FEAR OF
AROUSING SUSPICION. WHAT THIS
LOOKS LIKE ON LABOR AND
DELIVERY OUR PATIENTS WHO WANT
TO STAY PREGNANT AND THEIR
PARTNERS OR FAMILY MEMBERS WANT
TO TERMINATE. I HAD A PATIENT
COME IN THIS PAST WEEK WHOSE
PARTNER AND FAMILY MEMBER HAD
BEATEN HER PREGNANT ABDOMEN.
TRYING TO INDUCE A MISCARRIAGE
IT DIDN'T WORK IT RARELY WORKS
BUT THIS DIDN'T STOP IT FROM
HAPPENING. THIS IS WHAT
REPRODUCTIVE COERCION LOOKS
LIKE ON A DAILY BASIS AS AN
OBGYN AND I GUARANTEE YOU THAT
I ONLY SEE THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG. THIS NEEDS TO BE
RECOGNIZED FOR WHAT IT IS AN
INCREDIBLY POWERFUL FORM OF
CONTROL AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE SEVENTY FOUR. SEE
NONE AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. SEE NON OPERATOR WOULD
YOU OPEN THE LINESFOR THOSE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SEVENTY
FOUR AND AGAIN WE'RE TAKING
NAME AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT.
Q. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AT TEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE THREE IN Q. FOUR TO ONE
FIFTY ONE SEES FOR AT. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WILLIAM BUT BURKE ON BEHALF OF
NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RIGHT FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
MOLLY ROBESON WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF. IN
COURT AT EIGHT THREE SEVEN FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS ALEX KEPPLER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
RANGING QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU OPERATOR I DO NOT
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION LISTED IS
THERE ANYONE IN HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE SEVENTY FOUR. SEEING
NONE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN A
POSITION OF SB THREE SEVENTY
FOUR. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SP THREE SEVEN
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AT TEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMON THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND OPERATING MAKE CLOSE
ALLY ANSWERING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. MISCONDUCTS I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE GONNA SUPPORT THIS
THERE'S JUST ONE LINE IN THE-
ANALYSIS THAT I JUST HOPE WE
CAN BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
SPECIFIC- THREATENING TO LEAVE
A PARTNER IF THEY DO NOT BECOME
PREGNANT CAN BE A BIT BROAD
BECAUSE I THINK AND- ADULT
RELATIONSHIPS THE DECISION TO
HAVE CHILDREN SOMETIMES DOES OR
NOT HAVE CHILDREN AND COULD
RESULT IN IN A PARTNER LEAVING
ANOTHER PARTNER- AND I DON'T
THINK THAT'S NECESSARILY
OBVIOUSLY I THINK WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND REASONABLE THREAT
SIR. YOU KNOW FIRST OF IT JUST
SEEMS THAT I CAN THAT ONE
STATEMENT CAUGHT MY ATTENTION
IS LIKE WITH ANY NOW SYSTEM
PERMISSION TO RESPOND IT IS NOW
SAYS ON PAGE SIX AT THE VERY
BOTTOM AND IS IT IN THE
LEGISLATIVE LANGUAGE- IT WAS IN
THE ANALYSIS I DON'T BELIEVE
IT'S AN LEGISLATIVE I JUST WANT
TO POINT THAT OUT OF THAT COMES
IT IT SEEMS A BIT BROAD- TO
DEFINE. THAT IS COURSE- JUST ON
ITS FACE IF YOU WELL THE
STATEMENT ON ITS FACE. THAT'S A
GOOD POINT I AGREE WITH THAT
AND I BELIEVE AND I CAN TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS LEGISLATIVE
LANGUAGE IN A DETAIL BUT- I.
THINK THAT'S NOT REFLECTED IN
THE ACTUAL BILL LANGUAGE WHERE
THE BILL LANGUAGE DEFINES-
COMPELLING AS- THE OTHER
COMPELLING OTHER PARTY BY FORCE
THREAT OF FORCE OR
INTIMIDATION. INCLUDING THREATS
BASED ON ACTUAL OR SUSPECTED
IMMIGRATION STATUS TO ENGAGE IN
CONDUCT FROM WHICH THE OTHER
PARTY HAS A RIGHT TO STAINED.
OR UNSTAINED FROM CONDUCT IN
WHICH THE OTHER PARTY HAS
INCORRECT ENGAGED. I
REPRODUCTIVE CONCLUSION
CONSISTS OF CONTROL OF THE
REPRODUCTIVE AUTONOMY OF
ANOTHER THROUGH FOR SORT OF
FORCE OR INTIMIDATION. AND MAY
INCLUDE BUT IS NOT LIMITED TO
ON RECENTLY PRESSURING OTHER
PARTY TO BECOME PREGNANT.
DELIBERATELY INTERFERING WITH
CONTRACEPTION USE OR ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
INFORMATION. ARE USING COERCIVE
TACTICS TO CONTROL OR TEMP TO
CONTROL PREGNANCY OUTCOMES OF-
IN AND OUT WE HAVE EXAMPLES OF
COURSE OF CONTROL INCLUDE BUT
ARE NOT LIMITED TO ON RECENTLY
ENGAGING IN ANY OF THE
FOLLOWING. ISOLATING THE OTHER
PARTY FROM FRIENDS RELATIVES OR
OTHER PARTY SOURCES OF SUPPORT-
DEPRIVING OTHER PARTY BASIC
NECESSITIES CONTROLLING
REGULATING OR MONITORING THE
OTHER PARTIES MOVEMENTS
COMMUNICATIONS DAILY BEHAVIOR
FINANCES. ECONOMIC RESOURCES OR
ACCESS TO SERVICES UP I'M HAPPY
TO WORK WITH YOUR STAFF IF WE
CAN IDENTIFY ANY LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD BE PROBLEMATIC IN THE WAY
YOU DESCRIBE IT. I THINK WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS ISOLATE
UNREASONABLE COERCIVE BEHAVIOUR
I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH THE BILL
AGAIN IT WAS JUST THAT
STATEMENT NAY NOW SAYS THAT
CAUSED ME TO PAUSE A BIT- AND
THAT'S- NOT REFLECTED IN THE
pBILL SO IT JUST. WANTED TO
POINT OUT SOMETIMES PEOPLE READ
ANALYSIS AND THINK WHERE. SEEMS
A BIT- MAYBE. GETTING INTO
PEOPLE'S PERSONAL LIVES A
LITTLE BIT MORE THAN A WE
SHOULD AND SO I JUST WANT TO
WANT TO NOTE THAT GIVEN THAT
ANALYSIS THAT THAT JUST SEEMED
A BIT BROAD- NOT THE BILL
ITSELF THE BILL IS. VERY PRO
THEY DO THAT THAT'S A GOOD
POINT IN IT AND I THINK WITH
THE IN HOUSE IS DOING IS
POINTING OUT WITH SOME OF THE-
LITERATURE IS SAYING. ABOUT THE
SITUATION SO. THE POINT I
APPRECIATE. THE CLOSE ATTENTION
OF THAT AND- I SINCE I'M NEW TO
THE SENATE WILL- ASKING. WITH
MY- AND COMMITTEE STAFF TO SEE
WHAT WE CAN DO TO ADDRESS THE-
THAT. PARTICULAR LOT. YEAH I'M
NOT SURE THAT THE BILL ITSELF
NEEDS TO BE CHANGED. PERHAPS
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST YEAH. I
THINK YOU'RE- YOU'RE PROBABLY
FIVE. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. RIGHT SEEING NONE
SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
TEARS DOWN- THIS IS MY FIRST
BILL BEING PRESENTED ON THIS IN
THIS HOUSE AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME AND CLOSE
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL. I
BELIEVE THIS BILL IS AN
IMPORTANT ONE IT WILL SAVE
LIVES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE HI STONE I CHAO.
CHAO AYE CHIU. DAVIES DAVIES I
GONZALEZ. CONSULT AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA. KALRA AYE
KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN REYES REYES
R. SMITH. SMITH NOW. MENTION I.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. HI THERE BRINGS US TO ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT EIGHT J. R.
FOURTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
HARPER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AG ARE FOURTEEN WHAT ON
OF THE FORTY NINTH ANNIVERSARY
OF TITLE NINE PROTECTIONS
AGAINST SEXUAL BASED
DISCRIMINATION IN OUR SCHOOLS
AND WOULD URGE CALIFORNIA TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER. TO
ACHIEVE ITS GOAL OF MORE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR YOUTH.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU I DO THIS TO PEOPLE ALL THE
TIME AND I KNOW HOW I FEEL-
TITLE NINE OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
LAW MOST OF YOU KNOW ALL
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY
SCHOOLS SCHOOL DISTRICTS
COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES RECEIVING
FEDERAL FUNDING MST COMPLY
WITH I THINK WHEN WE LOOK AT
TITLE NINE AND WE LOOK AT THE
ADVANCES WE'VE REALLY MADE WE
NEED TO CELEBRATE THAT BUT ALSO
REMIND OURSELVES THAT THERE SO
FAR STILL TO GO. YOU KNOW SO
MANY OF US IN THIS ROOM WOULD
NOT BE HERE WERE IT NOT FOR
TITLE NINE SO MANY OF OUR
ATHLETIC CHAMPIONS LIKE OUR
WORLD YOU KNOW THE U. S.
NATIONAL SOCCER TEAM WOMEN'S
SOCCER TEAM ALL PLAY COLLEGIATE
ATHLETES ATHLETICS WE NEED TO
KEEP MOVING THE BALL FORWARD
AND BE ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF
HISTORY OF BEING MORE INCLUSIVE
AND HAVING MORE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITIES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU I DO NOT HAVE ANY. SUPPORT
WITNESSES LISTED IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF A J. R. FOURTEEN. SEEING
NONE AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU APPLIANCE FOR ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
SUPPORT FOR A G. R. FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF A AJ ARE
FOURTEENTH PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
TEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE COMMENTING
Q. RIGHT FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MONICA MURPHY ON BEHALF
OF EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU WE WILL MOVE TO A POSITION
I HAVE NO OPPOSITION WITNESSES
LISTED. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AJ ARE
FOURTEEN. SEEING NONE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OVER THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO GET OPPOSITION TO IT TO YOUR
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AJ
ARE FOURTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ARE PRETTY MAY
CLOSE ALLIANCE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMON. SEEING NONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND THAT MOTION IS THAT THE
RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED CALDERON
PLEASE STONE HI STONE I CHAO.
CHAO AYE CHU. CHU AYE DAVIES
DAVIES ARKANSAS LET'S CONSULT
AYE HOLDEN. HOLDEN I KALRA
KALRA AYE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN
MENTION I RAISE OUR RATES AYE
SMITH. THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO BACK THROUGH
ALL THE ITEMS ARE OUT. ADD
MEMBERS WHO HAVE YET TO VOTE
STARTING WITH THE CONSENT
AGENDA PLEASE CHU CHU I KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN IN
CHENNAI. THEN ITEM NUMBER ONE
SB FOUR FIFTY FOUR BATES CHU
CHU II HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE KILEY
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN MENTIONED
I REMEMBER TO SB FIFTY FOUR
COVER EUROPE. CHU CHU I. HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I MAIENSCHEIN MENTIONED
I. THANK YOU I REMEMBER THREE
SB TWO NINETY SEVEN TO ROSA CHU
CHU I. HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I. THEN
OUT OF NUMBER FOUR STR TO. TWO
I MAIENSCHEIN MAIN CHENNAI.
QUEUE ITE NUMBER FIVE SB FIVE
SEVENTY EIGHT JONES CHU CHU AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
RADIUS AYE RACE AYE. I REMEMBER
SIX SB THREE THIRTY ONE LEYVA
TO. CHIU I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I. I REMEMBER SEVEN
SB THREE SEVENTY FOUR MIN CHIU.
CHUGAI AND THEN I'VE NEVER
EIGHT HR FOURTEEN WE HAVE
EVERYONE RIGHT PERFECT THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH WE ARE
RETURNS.